And
we're live event words.
Ladies and gentlemen.
You're one of those dudes that has that book cover for your phone.
I tried to rock the book cover after awhile.
I'm like,
what am I doing here with this extra step?
I got to open up a book to get to my phone.
I like it because I forget things a lot so like I don't like having a wallet and
a phone when I leave somewhere like especially even in the house.
I leave the house in my phone but I don't have my cash on my car just so I've
got a solution for you.
It's called a motherfucking fanny pack.
That's right.
Even worse.
You're a cool dude.
You think you're cool enough to rock one of these like are you cool enough to
get past the social pariah aspect of this bag that you wear around your waist?
I don't have that much shit with me most of the time it's not that much shit is
a lot of shit in here,
but this is a weird day.
I have like keys and I have a knife in there and stuff,
but most of the time it's just light.
I travel light with that.
Look at that.
Who's gay?
Who's that?
I'd be like Calavo from Egos.
Uh,
I have no idea what he just said.
Popular Rapper,
but that is a ridiculous,
is he a popular fellow?
I know.
I'm an old man to listen to the Allman brothers.
All right.
But that one that he's got on his preposterous.
You might as well have a laptop hanging around his waist,
like holes in his jeans.
Yeah,
that's ridiculous.
What'd you get?
Attacked by a tiger,
sir.
Got a lot them jewelry.
All the jewelry in the 80s yeah,
he's kind of ridiculous looking.
Go,
but make that,
make that bigger again so I can take a look at this gentleman
light version two.
I probably could have found a better place.
He's got a lot going on.
Those pants are preposterous.
That's the most preposterous thing.
Like I guess the shoes.
If you were like,
you want to go out,
but you also want to go bowling,
you might wear the shoes.
This is a rose fascinates go.
I can't say anything bad about the jewelry.
I'm not into the jewelry.
I mean I'm,
that's not my thing.
But he looks like he's well appointed.
Two watches on though.
Fuck yeah,
I'm balling.
Hashtag [inaudible] I think the one on the right is probably just,
is that a bracelet bracelet?
Just a fancy ass bracelet.
Uh,
but the pants are ridiculous.
I don't,
how the fuck did that ever get started where people were ripped up pants.
I tried to talk to Brendan Schaub about that.
That dumb motherfucker.
Where's those [inaudible] they did a long time.
Exactly.
It's been going on for a while.
Music videos.
I just like,
what are you doing man?
It's like Pat Benatar.
I don't have any fashion tastes.
Don't listen to me,
but when I'm Moxham some shit,
you might want to listen to me.
Like don't wear what I wear.
Like,
you know,
don't just don't,
I mostly wear either I'll wear like these things which are like a trail running
sneakers.
They get no sneaker cred or I'll wear like converse all star.
Oh,
look at this.
Look at this teen beat.
Donnie Wahlberg.
Yeah,
exactly.
How does his hog not just slipped right out of that one on the right,
right hand side.
That one on the right hand side come on.
Silly Fox
like I don't know.
I see that and I feel like it guys will probably went in a thong under that too.
Yeah,
I would imagine there's something going on like with with the women,
like it's,
it's so much nicer to me at all.
I'm going to tell you right now,
this is where I'm a hypocrite.
Like with Beyonce right there.
She fills it out.
Yeah,
she does that.
See that's kind of different because like a woman's legs and everything are very
sexual.
Right?
So you've see extra leg.
It's like just shut your mouth and take the bonus.
Yeah.
Right.
You don't want to complain about it,
but a dude wearing something like that,
it's like it's,
it's literally like,
well not literally,
but it's so much like a guy wearing a dress.
It's a fashion for women.
I believe it's trying way too hard.
Like this.
Look at this fellow.
He this like seems like the 80s though.
Cause he's got a suit jacket on.
I mean you can look at the quality of picture.
Yeah,
right.
That's true.
That hairstyle.
The suit suit jackets never came back.
Got Patches too.
Oh,
he's got patches.
Yeah.
I remember when they used to do all that art on the,
on the genes to,
yeah,
that was those pants.
Those pants were ridiculous,
but ripped up pants.
Men allegedly ripped up pants and,
and,
and skinny Jean.
I,
I'm like,
I'm still 100% against skinny jeans.
You know what I say that I'm against gain jeans,
but I wear these things called barbell jeans.
You ever wear those?
They look like skinny jeans because they,
they're tight to you.
But they have,
oh,
I don't mind.
I know this is,
they're made out of,
yeah.
Shit.
They got some,
some,
some elasticity.
Oh yeah man.
They're like wearing sweat pants like you don't fit if you don't feel you go
throw kicks in him like you could like for real.
I'm too old for it now.
I'm not going to get my leg.
No,
no,
no.
Do you train anymore?
Yeah,
I still train.
I haven't trained the past few months have been a little bit hard,
but now that things are settling down,
settling into this new life,
um,
things are good.
Um,
been training with Joe a lot.
Schilling.
Oh,
okay.
Quickie garlic just moved out here.
And you were in that area?
In the downtown area and Eagle Rock.
Oh,
nice.
Nice.
I like it over there.
The yard's great players.
The Yard is awesome.
That's a great place to train.
Been going there for a while.
I saw Mickey training with Joe on Instagram.
Yup.
Yeah.
Nice.
So sound.
They're too smart.
Good move for him.
That's what he needs,
right?
It's striking his ground game.
He's very good.
Yeah,
his ground is really good.
He moved down here about a month ago and he actually,
he's my roommate now.
No Shit.
And you live with Micky Gall is,
yeah,
he came out.
That's cool.
Oh,
that's gotta be fun.
It's fun.
Also because he's so young.
It's almost like having a son that is doing what you did.
You know,
I took great resource for him to be able to talk to you.
Ask Your questions about the game.
We sit around and watch fights sometimes it's good.
Eve Edwards,
I saw you fight and hook and shoot in like the fucking sixties.
Like you were wearing bell bottoms when he came out to the cage?
I was,
there was one.
Yeah,
I remember you fought Aaron Riley.
I think you were like 12 years old.
How old were you?
I was about 20.
I was still a kid.
Those were good fights man.
Those were good fights.
That was,
um,
I was watching that fight actually Mickey and I watched that fight together a
couple of weeks ago.
Um,
is it weird?
It is weird because it seemed like you,
does it seem like another life?
It's kind of another life,
right?
Is like how old are you now?
I'm 41 when you,
when you think back about yourself at 20,
like how much memory do you really have that he got like little flashes.
Like,
I could see little pick images of h and then I have a narrative that it play out
in my head that I think happened and so I can repeat it.
Here we go.
Look at that 20 year old bouncing around.
Wow Dude.
Yeah,
no,
look at it here.
Wow.
Yeah.
You had like does curl thing going on and yeah,
they're Kool Moe Dee thing going on too.
I was,
you know,
I was representing,
wow.
I just fighting those really surely days.
This was,
um,
Jeff Osborne show can shoot.
That was the first time you were in a knife fight.
He's a really good commentator,
man.
Is he working?
I don't know.
I know he just shut down hook and shoot.
Yeah,
it's gone.
And I don't know what Jeff is doing.
I know he had a lot.
He was,
he was involved with pro wrestling a lot too.
Um,
but now I haven't spoken to him in a long time.
I had a couple of shows with him in the UFC when I first came aboard.
He was,
he was doing the UFC back in the day.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I was just Wah.
That's another thing.
Going back and watching these old fights,
I've been on fight pass and I was watching,
I think it was like you're [inaudible] wow.
Um,
when Louisiana,
when boosted match and Linden that card.
Yeah.
That was the restart fight.
Exactly.
Remember that on that card?
My Tim and I tapped him again.
Big John kind of screwed it up and yeah,
man,
you know that that was the early days too.
I think nowadays I think big John would have just said,
no,
no.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
I mean we were all learning back then,
but that was still like UFC middleweight championship and it was like they had
had 30 plus shows.
It was like,
it was something that you wouldn't expect for sure.
Lynn Lynn was so is so crazy.
Didn't he bite somebody and when he was wrestling Lynn Lynn,
yeah.
Yeah.
In the wrestling days he bit somebody here's boosting launch versus chocolate
Dell.
This is a different one.
Yeah.
This was a fight where boosted monsters out power and he was just too small.
Chuck was just so scary back then and he boosted,
much wasn't taking chuck down.
Well,
boosting Monch had fought some big fucking dudes though,
man.
Yeah.
That was the thing that he hadn't taken chucked out.
He had fought some big fucking dude's.
Remember he fought Tom Erickson in like world combat something or another?
I don't remember the organization.
I do vaguely remember the fight.
I don't remember watching it,
but um,
they,
it was,
uh,
it was a mat.
I don't,
I feel like it was on a mat and there was no cage or oil ring.
Mabee you might be right.
Right.
That's what my dream is.
My dream is to do a MMA fights in a football field.
I feel like I'm speaking for football fields.
No.
So you can't get trapped up against the cage.
I feel like if a guy takes you down and holds you down,
he should be able to hold you down because there's nothing there.
But the ground.
Yeah,
but a cage,
you can wall walk up the cage there.
You could protect yourself against submissions up against the cage.
There's a bunch of shit that happens against the cage that just doesn't happen
if you're in a basketball court.
But then because of that you got to develop new technique.
Right.
You've got to develop something to deal with that situation.
Yeah.
Are you,
um,
like do you think the rules are okay?
No.
What do you,
what would you change?
I um,
I would definitely change the 12 to six elbow.
That's one I only got the big way.
Um,
you know why that one's illegal,
right?
Yeah.
So stupid.
I used to watch those,
those um,
demonstration used to come on late at night on ESPN and I was a kid.
I used to watch those things all the time.
I used to love him too.
Even when even when I was fighting,
I was still watching those things because it was at a Damon.
It,
those things are so silly
though.
They,
they get,
they get so intense to,
you know,
the athletic commissions really thought that you couldn't do that to a person
because you'd kill them.
So they made that technique illegal at all this shit.
Like we have that power cube thing in the back where Ghana gone registered that
power punch.
If you go all there at elbow,
that thing,
you'd be shocked at how weak ass her elbows,
especially a dropdown elbow.
Like it's just not that much power.
It's just,
I mean when they're breaking those boards,
if they're using that,
that joint as a,
as a,
as a post as the letter.
Exactly.
And they're just putting their body weight behind it.
That's all it is.
You can't necessarily do that when you're inside someone's guard.
You don't want John Jones elbow new in the face period.
Exactly.
No difference.
If John's hitting you with a downward elbow,
like he got disqualified for when he fought Matt Hamill or if he's hitting you
with a sideways elbow,
he's going smashing you.
You know what,
that download elbow is going to cut a lot less and less.
It's the point on the top of the head.
That's true.
That's,
that's a very important point.
Like that was always the,
um,
the argument against no gloves was that you'd cut,
he'd cut people wanting.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
I mean that that skin getting pinched between bone at that speed,
you know,
she's getting torn,
it's not really cut.
But do you think that having wrapped up hands and having padded gloves,
like is that an unrealistic sort of thing?
Because like if you're,
if you're striking,
if you in a dude,
we're just fighting,
right?
You're just fighting.
Like there's no like,
hey,
this is a play fight and we're going to have rules.
This is just a fight you and a guy are fighting.
You can't just hit them with bare hands.
The way you can hit them with gloves on with your wrist taped up,
you know,
you,
you gotta be very wary about punching him full blast and the forehead.
You might shatter your hand.
There's a lot of things you have to think about.
Yeah.
But I guess as as if someone has done it and trained to,
to try to knock someone out,
but you're not thinking about you.
We never throwing punches at your skull.
Right.
You know,
we're,
we're aiming for these targets that are soft for sure.
So like when you're in a street fight,
like those things don't turn off.
So,
so as a fighter,
I,
I'm,
that's not a concern to me in a street fight situation when you bring that up.
Um,
but I know it can happen.
I mean it happened in some of the early UFC guys guys break their hands on
skulls.
That's what I'm saying.
Is it unrealistic to put gloves on?
So I'm going to tape the wrist up when we don't give them any other advantage
for striking and any other way you don't let them cast up your ankles or do
something where you,
you know,
your protect your shins and make it easier for you to kick hard.
Cause if you had like some sort of spandex thing with a,
uh,
like a Shin Pad,
like,
like the same sort of thickness of Shim pad as you have on the knuckles,
you would just be slamming into everything,
you know,
elbows,
arms.
Who gives a fuck?
You wouldn't worry about it.
Just slamming in there.
Boom.
It would change the game.
A W W it would completely change the game,
but it would,
it would slow it down a lot more.
I mean,
in MMA fights now that you look at a punched out for him and may five versus a
boxing match,
you know,
of course they can only punch so,
so the punch counts higher but your hands are getting hurt.
You know,
guys,
guys will lose fights simply because they can't continue going into the second
round sometimes.
Will that be the case or will it change their style?
It will definitely change the style,
but without having the gloves and hand wraps and that stuff there,
there is going to be those times when it's still going to,
it's just going to minimize,
not minimize but bring the number down.
It's not going to stop it though.
I agree.
Um,
I mean I think if I wanted to look at it in terms of just pure entertainment
value,
I'd say leave it the way it is.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Changed downward elbows.
Checked out a couple of other things.
Yes.
Some,
some things like I liked pride rules.
Yeah.
So bad rules,
including with the judging.
The pride.
It was judge,
the whole fight drives the whole fight.
I agree with that.
I like that.
And I think I'm more judges,
you know.
Um,
but I think that's a big one I was talking about with that with Pat Miletich
show the day were saying like five judges are more,
you know,
why only three?
Yeah,
I agree.
And I agree with more judges that you will get a little more diversity.
Also though I think,
um,
you got to change,
change the scoring criteria.
I mean we are using a boxing criteria,
but like,
like when you talk about wrestling and when I see guys go,
oh,
he's going to take that.
When a guy goes down,
he pops right back up.
I'm like,
this is not a take down.
It's not too so,
so like why can't we implement some of the things,
because we're taking aspects of all these different styles of fighting,
like the,
the scoring system and the values for things should,
should come from that to some degree.
Yeah.
I would take down with the immediate standup.
Like,
if someone takes you down,
you're right back up.
That is not a whole lot different than you blocking the kick.
Yeah.
You know,
does blocking a kick count if you get your knee up and your elbow up and you
catch one right here,
are you counting that as something that got through right?
No,
no you're not.
So you know who does right?
Jackson,
he's a great coach and I don't say he.
So he,
I think he does this psychological thing.
I'm letting the cat out of the bag,
but this way,
cause I'm in the cage with,
with Isaac Valley flag and Isaac throws a kick and I block it and Greg is like,
it's a great kick.
Isaac Greg Kick like that landed me,
you know,
and I'm like,
and then he does something else and it doesn't affect me,
but he's cheering him on like it does.
And I'm like,
is he doing that for the rat,
for the judges?
Cause that I'm like,
I went back to the corner,
I told Mike,
I was like,
Mike,
he's,
he's cheering them on and getting kind of getting the judges on his side.
Mike's like,
don't worry about that.
This is what you need to do.
Yeah.
You gotta get that shit out of your head.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
But if he's right there,
it'll give you see where one corner is and then the other corner is when the
fight is not going on there,
over there by the stairs.
The judge is right there.
Yup.
The judges just a few feet over and if they're looking enthusiastic,
like,
yes,
you gotta,
you gotta those judges a certain percent,
let's say 30 don't know what the fuck they're watching and so they're very soon
we say a name.
No,
I'm just,
no,
let's not say any names because I know what we'd say.
We'd all say the same name,
unfortunately.
Nice Lady.
Anyway,
this,
this fucking situation is there should be way better judges for sure.
Yeah.
I think guys who were former fighters,
guys who are martial arts experts,
guys who like really care about the sport,
you have no shortage of them.
You can go to any MMA school,
any Jujitsu school,
Eddie kickboxing school,
any websites,
any website all across the country.
And you will find hundreds and hundreds of qualified candidates.
People that will tell you why that's a bad decision.
People that'll tell you why that doesn't work.
People will tell you why this shouldn't mean anything.
And we don't have that right now for no reason.
There's like zero reason.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's not like,
wow man,
there's not enough money.
Like what is this?
No,
there's enough money for it.
This is this crazy.
This is no reason.
It's not like,
well,
you know,
water's wet and that's just how it goes.
No,
that would be,
I think it would be a good thing also now that like the second generation I,
I have like in my head,
I have this three generations of them may and that's where we are now in the
third starting to move into the fourth.
Um,
and I feel like with the first two generations being done pretty much.
Yeah.
Like there's a lot of guys that are highly qualified to,
to play more,
you know,
then it may mean the sport is giant.
There's so many good writers out there.
If you read MMA articles,
they're really good writing and a lot of these like mainstream websites SLAAC a
lot of experts out there talking
about stuff.
That's why a fight like next weekend is so fascinating because between Tony and
could be,
nobody knows what the fuck is going to happen.
It's one of those fights where everybody's like,
damn,
I don't know.
And you got all these people breaking it down on one side and then you've got
people making compelling arguments on the other side and you're like,
okay,
this one's going to be weird.
I've been,
I've been bouncing back and forth between my pick for that fight.
But,
um,
I guess because I've been bouncing back and forth,
this isn't necessarily where I'm going to stay,
but I,
I feel like,
okay,
I don't see how that can change.
But again,
like you said,
there are people that are making these arguments and if somebody convinces me of
something that kinda defeats this argument,
then it's like,
man,
now you opened the door for this again.
And what I think is like what I first,
my first thought was could be,
he was this guy,
he takes everybody down and he controls you and beat you up and you think he's
going to do that.
And then,
um,
but Tony is this guy,
he just does not,
he's like one of these submission first kind of guys.
You know,
where that argument,
submission or position told him he wasn't even too worried about the position.
He'll create scrambles.
He's,
he's aware of where he is at all times and what he's giving up.
So I feel like he would just continue to scramble.
He'd be able to get back to his feet at least.
Um,
and then I go back to Khabib and seeing Tony Against Kevin Lee and Kevin Lee
kind of control him early in that fight.
You know,
he was able to pass his guard and do some,
some good controlling things.
Now.
If a guy like could be,
you can do that.
Right then he's not getting back up and could be,
he was going to be able to take him down.
He is the best wrestler in the game.
Like without a doubt.
Yeah.
Make good arguments.
Good arguments.
You know,
I think another argument is it Kevin,
when Kevin Lee fought Tony,
I think everybody knew Kevin had a staph infection.
I knew I saw him walking to the cage.
I look at his chest.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
that guy's got staff.
I knew it was going to be weak.
I knew in compared to the Kevin Lee,
the destroyer that you see when he's on point and in shape,
I was like,
this guy is going to be compromised.
Yeah,
and he's also a big one 55 so it's a hard cut for him.
Whereas Tony makes it mean Tony can get pretty heavy,
but he's super disciplined.
He makes it easy.
Tony's endurance,
his endurance is off the charts,
off the charts impeccable.
He was posting the other day that he went on a six,
six mile run at one o'clock in the morning.
It's like extra credit.
He wrote Hashtag extra credit.
I mean he's an animal.
I mean Eddie Bravo trains of them up there in big bear all the time.
[inaudible] he said he's never seen anything like it.
So to do is just everybody else like pace and everybody up the hill coming back
down.
They're still trying to make it up the first time he's running past them.
The second time he's a fucking animal.
Like aw,
he wants it bad.
But so he knew that Kevin goes into that fight was compromised.
So if he knew Kevin was compromised,
maybe he decided just to let them work.
Let them work that first round.
Yeah.
And Kevin's don't know joke.
Kevin's fucking dangerous.
Very skilled.
Very skilled,
very aggressive.
Very strong.
Very dangerous.
You know.
So Tony,
he got in bad positions in that fight though,
didn't he get mounted?
He gets routed.
He is guy got pretty convinced,
like pretty easily early in the fight.
Um,
but that's crazy because if,
if he,
if he did take that time off,
even knowing that a guy like Kevin Lee was,
you know,
compromised,
that's still a high level guy to be,
um,
take this time off.
It'll be a little bit laxed.
Might just have been Kevin.
Is that good?
I really wish that fight took place with Kevin Healthy.
Really wish that fight took place with Kit Kat.
I said Kevin is an interesting guy because he's,
he talks a lot of shit.
Yeah.
He's really aggressive.
He fights well.
He looks the part,
when you look at him,
he's fucking jacked.
You know,
that's a bad break for a dude like that.
He had like a golf ball growing out of his tit.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
I mean,
it could happen again relatively soon depending on how it was fight with with
Barboza goes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's an interesting fight for Barboza tube are,
has got to recover from that.
Mauling the can you put on them that was horrendous.
But you know,
I'm an opponent to Tony.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I want to look back at,
um,
the Barbosa fight.
But when I,
when I did look at it,
he defended,
he defended some of those takedowns early,
you know what I mean?
It's against,
could be eve now.
Yes.
You can defend,
you're going to be the strongest in the first round,
but still,
um,
there's not a lot of people defending,
could be his takedowns.
No.
You know,
um,
there's a great New York Times article that was us just on,
or three or four days ago about wrestlers from Dagestan.
Yeah.
And about how wrestling is their way out because so many of them trying to prove
themselves,
they wind up joining those Islamic terrorist groups and,
uh,
that these coaches try to take these young,
aggressive kids and give them something,
something,
something else and give them another alternative,
really,
really well written article.
Interesting stuff about like how powerful these guys are and how young they get
him into it.
And when you see Khabib,
the thing about him,
it's like he's not doing different things and everybody else,
you know what I mean?
Like some people are doing different things like wonder boy is doing different
things.
Like he stands totally sideways,
his hands are down.
He's throwing front leg sidekicks.
Yeah,
he's doing a lot of different things and you're like,
oh,
okay,
this is some,
a new thing to adjust to.
It could be labs doing standard shit,
but he's just doing it at not just our notch but several notches past what
everybody else is doing.
I think that's the thing about these Dagestani guys.
Um,
it's crazy because like,
it's this American wrestling style,
folk style wrestling of being on top and having that control.
That's a big deal.
But like Nick Lens,
that's one of his strengths.
When nick gets on top of you,
it's like a,
a Dorf,
you know,
like he's not going anywhere,
but he can also escape that.
A lot of guys,
same thing with Mike Brown,
but um,
Nick Lance got written out at the w in,
in the fight in Brooklyn.
I forget which car that I'm Holly Holmes and Jermaine Mandarin to me.
You know that car he wanted by getting right?
No,
the ones launch one which fight,
I forget who,
who he fought,
I forget he fought a Dagestani guy.
Oh.
But he just got written out against his own style.
Like that's what I'm saying.
These guys are better at what they are with the American style is.
But like for something like that,
I want to see one of those guys against a guy like Greg Gillespie,
you know,
cause that style of wrestling of being on top and grinding on you.
That's a high like a high level wrestler like that and no fault out four time.
All American national champion kind of guy with that kind of conditioning who's
not going to break.
I want to see that battle.
That's like,
cause that'll be like a a Nash National Championship with two guys that can
punch and kick a bit.
Well look at guy like Jordan Burroughs or Jordan Burroughs getting into mmn.
Yeah.
Like what happens when he fights when those Dagestani guys.
Yeah,
exactly.
But see there's Dagestani guys and then it's could beep.
He's another notch above them.
He's a notch above them.
Like,
there's a lot of those guys that are real good.
They're real tough,
you know,
but he's another level.
He is a scary level when you see him on top of guys,
like,
like especially the Michael Johnson,
that was helpless.
That was mauling man,
horrifying.
And having a conversation with him,
pleading with him to give up,
you must quit title shut this mind,
you know,
title shot they deserve.
Bam just keeps,
and he's got his arm tied behind his back is punching him in the face.
It's horrific.
I mean,
he can do shit to you that like,
it's like white belt,
black belt beat up.
It's against the best guy in the world against the best guys in the world.
Michael Johnson.
Michael Johnson clipped him.
No,
but here's the thing about that fight.
It's interesting to me.
It could be came into that fight with the same problem.
He went into the Tony Ferguson fight that was canceled.
He cut too much weight and his liver apparently shutdown making wait for that
fight.
So then they went into the next fight.
Um,
and he didn't make weight at all.
Rushed to the hospital.
Then he hired a nutritionist.
Looks fucking fantastic.
Event Against Barboza has zero problems making weight and now he's got it all
under control.
But you got to wonder if he was compromised in the Michael Johnson fight.
How much of a factor did that play into the him getting stunned.
Yeah,
he got,
he got clipped,
he got clipped.
And you know as well as anybody that when you're dehydrated or you have been
dehydrated,
you just don't take a punch as well.
Yeah,
yeah.
Dehydration,
conditioning,
those things.
You know,
those things help you recover when you,
when you're hydrated and you're conditioning is,
is up to.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
He,
you seen him take some punches.
He always backs guys up.
He's always coming forward and he does eat a lot of shots coming forward.
But you know,
if his conditioning is fine and that's the only time that I can remember him
getting hurt in a fight and from taking shots,
like the same thing with Barbosa,
Barbosa,
who was thrown at him hard,
hard,
you know,
especially,
yeah,
just stuff.
Everything.
He's like a Zombie.
He got wheel kicked a couple of times.
It's not the club in the back of the head would wheel kicks.
Nope.
Sorry.
Not Today.
Just constantly charging forward.
He's
a fucking tank.
Terrifying guy.
But this is the fight.
To me that's the most intriguing.
Other than him fighting Conor,
him fighting Conor for the name value.
It's like chaos,
right?
Like Holy Shit.
Like they might do that.
If he wins,
he might do that.
Do that Russia,
dude,
if they do that,
Russia,
Connor better bring his own food.
I tell you that.
Hey,
better bring some fucking corn,
beef and cabbage right from the motherland.
You don't want to take any chances.
But when Khabib,
um,
when Khabib's fighting Tony,
the thing about Tony is that Tony so creative,
like he's very unpredictable.
You don't know what he might step in and throw an upward elbow.
You know,
he,
he'll do all kinds of weird shit.
He'll do Granby rolls on you.
He'll die for a leg.
You know,
he might try to take Khabib down.
Who knows what he's going to do and stand up.
He's got legit knockout power,
legit.
And he can take a shot.
Rolls with punches real well,
doesn't mind.
When he gets hit hard,
he just kind of rolls with Shit,
comes back like the Barboza fight.
The Barboza fight with him was a very interesting fight.
Yeah.
That,
that fight was fun to watch.
Like I can't,
I can't remember all the details right now,
but I remember thinking,
I remember tweeting,
man,
I'm watching this and these guys are savages.
I,
I can't,
I can't believe I thought one of these days I have bad daddy can steal.
It's like,
man,
I fought them both.
But yeah,
that,
that fight was fun to watch.
And that's,
that's that common opponent thing that you say and yeah.
I don't know.
It's one of those things also though,
because you know the rule fighter ABC,
that thing doesn't play out like stout beats,
like stat Jeremy Stevens beats down.
I'd beat Jeremy and Jeremy.
That would be,
to me,
it's this crazy,
crazy thing where it just doesn't add up.
It doesn't add up.
MMA.
Math just doesn't work.
It's one of the reasons why someone like a could be so impressive.
It's cause he beats everybody.
Everyone undefeated.
Yeah.
Who the fuck is undefeated at that level?
The game,
I think he has 25 victories is f five and 25 at Oh him and that's the other
thing like I still called John Jay.
I called him one defeated because Jon Jones,
he's undefeated in my book cause nonsense.
You know when when you get smashed.
Exactly.
He dominated that fight.
100% was a,
it's a goofy rule and I don't even know if he totally violated it.
I mean he's trying to get through the guard while he's finishing a guy guys
covering up stupid.
It makes me mad.
I feel like it hit a nerve.
It that one time at the 12 to six help.
It makes me mad because it makes me mad because it's still there because they
changed the rules like they went through this new unified rule system.
I'm like,
oh this is good.
We have some new regulations as far as like putting your hand on the mat and
getting,
taking a knee,
you know like when,
when can you hit a guy with a knee?
Now it's one hand,
now you can do it with one hand.
Great.
I like that.
What Donna's 12,
six elbows still in c,
here's,
here's what I've learned since I've retired,
is that all of these formulas fit into something.
So right now
you're like,
well you change this one thing,
will all this other shit is wrong?
Well,
you look at society and you look at the world,
right?
And like these little changes or what happens,
it's never,
everything that's wrong is in fixed at all times.
It's always as one little things fixed.
This other little things fixed.
There's a little things,
you know what I mean?
So it's gonna take a while.
It'll happen eventually.
But man,
there is so much in the,
like there should be something that changes every year.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think they,
they've got to figure out something with the I pokes.
Yeah.
I feel like there's,
I think some,
I dunno,
he might have been you.
I feel,
cause it was,
it was,
uh,
an announcer or a commentator or something talking about it,
but having like a,
a glove just to covers the fingers,
but it doesn't really change anything.
Even,
even so much so that like it's a webbing and that your fingers are still
virtually individual,
you know,
but you can bring them all down together or you can just put those two on and
these two are going to be tugged that,
but it takes no effort.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Some things that are covering like that with the padding over the front so that
it doesn't go in the eyes as a single point.
But
is there anybody even playing with prototypes or something like that and doing
an exhibition or demonstration to,
good question.
You know,
I haven't seen anything compelling.
I haven't seen anybody come up with anything.
Yeah.
It was my idea.
My idea was to have it like,
um,
like,
like uh,
like old school,
bad glove.
Yeah.
You know,
like Joe Lewis with those old school bad gloves because it's a very thin glove.
They would cover the tips and they used to hit the bag with them back in like
the fucking twenties.
Yeah.
It was just like leather and,
and maybe maybe that's what it is.
Like,
um,
Keith still got love and just kind of a topping of that type of thing.
That makes so much sense.
Yeah.
Why would the tips of the fingers,
like you don't in grappling,
you never use individual,
no cop.
Everything is done like this.
Yeah.
It wouldn't change anything.
Nothing at all.
And change a single thing though.
The only thing it changes is,
is yeah,
cause he,
it doesn't even change this.
No,
no.
I'm still here.
It makes it better honestly.
You have more grip.
Yeah.
Like if it's like a,
you know,
like um,
suede material,
like something that's a little rough,
you could actually get good.
Yeah,
that's true.
It would help grappling because gloves definitely hurt some submissions they get
in the way of rear naked chokes.
It's one of the reasons why Georgia submission over Bisping was so impressive
because he went this way.
You know,
he went deep back of the hand to the back of the neck,
the real way,
which you don't sometimes you don't see because the guy can't get the glove in
there.
Yeah.
That's the one that's on the,
on the display image of like,
of,
of Jujitsu jokes.
I mean that one was fucking tight.
That was crazy to watch George dude.
But yeah,
they've got to figure out something.
You don't need to have these open,
it doesn't affect risk control.
It doesn't affect any kind of grappling in,
in,
in fact it would make it better.
What does bell tour?
There's one.
Yeah,
Bella tour has done,
what pride did you,
are they curved it?
I like it.
They use an Everlast.
Everlast is their glove manufacturer.
Obviously they make fucking killer shit,
but um,
what they're doing is having it so it's,
it's more difficult to open your fingers up.
That's a smart move.
It's a little little thicker.
So you didn't see a lot of,
um,
I tried.
No,
you didn't.
That's the point,
right?
Yeah.
It was very,
it was the UFC,
those gloves,
it's almost harder to close than it is to,
to open them.
Yeah.
And then,
I don't know,
I feel like maybe it was just the commission,
but I feel like,
you know,
you always break it gloves then you tried to break a man and let,
cause they're stiff when you first get them.
They're new.
Um,
but there was at least one commission.
They,
they wouldn't even let us like,
you know,
break the gloves and they wouldn't give you the gloves you had.
You didn't get them until you put them on.
That must be some amateur shit.
Like some commission.
It doesn't know what they're doing yet.
You all commission doesn't know what they're doing.
Not,
not the commission.
Um,
the hospitals after the,
after the fight itself in New York,
really mad in Brooklyn.
I had the,
the,
the crazy,
well I had,
it wasn't me.
Dustin poray had the craziest trip.
We,
so after that fight with Jim Miller with all those shin cakes,
they were both,
they both went to the hospital with a calf kicks and I'm Dustin's calf and Shin
was swollen and they will,
I'm giving him some morphine and truck.
We got there and they,
the doctor came in and they wanted to perform a surgery on him there.
They wanted to slice his shin open,
um,
and relieve the pressure because they were saying,
you're going to lose nerve tissue and your nerves are going to die.
And,
and um,
you,
if you start not feeling when they go,
there's no,
and there's no coming back.
You can't fix it.
You can't fix those things.
Um,
they were really pushing for this thing.
It was just a crazy situation.
Right.
So we're like,
hey,
Dustin,
man.
And then I called Mike Brown back then and we started having this discussion
about,
it's just like,
it's leg kicks.
We've seen this all the time and the thigh and whatnot.
No,
when they're not in,
Dustin was like,
yeah,
I don't want to do that.
Um,
then they started,
he was like,
yeah,
I want to get out of here basically.
And he was like,
can I just have something for the pain?
And it felt like they were like,
no.
They said,
no,
we're not going to let you leave here on pain medication.
And I felt like they were trying to keep him the entice him to stay fucking pain
medication.
It was just a really weird situation.
And we were there for way too long and they were really pushing for this like
three or four different doc.
No three different doctors came in and trying to convince him to get this
surgery done.
Wow.
It was crazy.
Just for some swelling to swelling in the calf.
That doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't,
I honestly think that it would cause nerve damage to have so much swelling.
The swelling was pushing up against the blood vessel supposedly.
And there wasn't,
um,
circulation coming through that to what was,
oh,
this is,
this is what I,
and this is a over a year ago,
so I'm trying to remember exactly.
And I'm not a met,
I'm not a doctor.
Um,
but the,
the swell and they were asking him about,
um,
cause he was having some,
some loss of sensation right.
And his toes,
but he had just fought,
you know,
and they'd given him morphine and all this other stuff.
So,
um,
maybe no poking at his toes with a pin or something.
You feel that he feel that and he's like,
yeah,
a little bit.
No,
you know these different answers.
And um,
they would,
they claim to be concerned about it.
They were telling him that this is what,
this is a possibility and this is what's going to happen and we want to prevent
it.
They weren't like,
well this is guaranteed that this is what's going on.
This is just the realistic possibility and we want to prevent it.
And it was just like,
he wanted to wait as long as possible and they were just,
they just seem to be really pushy about wanting to do this.
So where would they're going to make the incision in?
In the Shin
up the shin.
How big?
It was big.
It was just as long as my phone.
What?
So that list instead.
That's why we were like,
yeah,
this is kind of crazy.
And they were just want to drain it and they want to drain it.
They want to release the pressure.
Right.
And then they were like,
well,
we can,
there's a test that we can do.
You can't really see it from that angle.
But then it was so much worse than the hospital.
They were like,
there's,
uh,
he,
when Dustin was like,
I don't,
I don't like that idea.
I don't want to do that.
And they were,
I don't think that let's just wait.
And he's like,
well,
they were like,
there's a thing that we can do,
but we have to take a needle.
And they wanted to take a neat along needle,
stick it into his leg,
past the bone into the muscle and like do a pressure test on it.
And he was like,
yeah,
I don't like,
it was crazy because he doesn't like needles.
Right.
That's the HDLs.
And I'll be like,
all these title fights were living scared of needles.
I'm the same way about needles,
but I don't have the tattoos that kid has,
but he's just like,
I don't want to do that.
I don't want like,
he's like,
no,
cause they wanted it would have been this much in it inside his shit.
Yeah.
I don't know how long it would have been,
but it wasn't.
Yeah,
it wasn't just like looking for vein and they were just testing for pressure.
They will,
they will like talk and they was saying they wanted to test her tire gauge in
there and showed exactly doing
so,
so anyway,
they didn't happen.
The dust we started,
Dustin's started getting frustrated and,
and,
and they really pushing for it.
It was late at night and I don't think I was helping the situation because I was
like,
these guys are probably interns.
They probably back there with like a chart and they're like,
they get,
they get bonus points for whatever surgery that he can,
you know,
you never know,
man.
People are really skeptical about our kind of stuff.
But you know what I mean?
They definitely do surgeries on people that you don't have to.
Some doctors too.
It definitely can happen.
I mean,
you'd hope that you're not running into one of those doctors,
but they have done it before.
Yeah.
I mean there's a doctor that got just got arrested recently and there was a
whole story about all the different surgeries that he did that he didn't have to
do and including cancer surgeries,
like he removed cancer on people that didn't even have cancer.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a scam.
Just started driving fat.
Mercedes got to make those payments.
He should just got into the plastic surgery business.
I know,
right?
Do you could talk those crazy ladies into to anything,
anything and everything.
You need some unique,
you need to take some of that meat out of your button.
Putting your lips.
Yeah.
That's the move.
Meaty Buck Lips.
So will they ice in the Shin the entire time?
They were.
They had ice on it.
They had a drip,
like a morphine drip to kill the pain.
Why didn't they just wait a couple of days while they want to just go right into
it right now?
They wanted,
they wanted to do it that night and they,
they said,
they said they didn't want or the reason why they didn't want to wait was
because when the nerve nerve damage happens,
when the nerves die,
that's it.
They're debt.
There's no way to,
you know,
to bring those things back.
So man,
I just uh,
I wonder what if that's right.
I don't want to be taught at shit about the doctors.
It's not right because Dustin fought again after that.
Eddie both flag and he's fighting in a few weeks.
Like when was his leg better?
Um,
shoot,
he got on a plane the next day,
so I had a hat.
Real quick little side note.
I had had some problems.
I was helping him for that camp and I had an injury and um,
I got Tylenol with codeine in it and man,
that stuff,
that's,
that's powerful medicine.
How powerful is that?
It was po.
I was like,
I couldn't,
Dustin took me to the hospital.
I know I went in,
I was,
I was in so much pain and they were like,
they prescribed that I took one pill and about 20 minutes later I was like,
it was the first time I was able to relax and like three days the pain was so
bad and I was like,
when I get bad,
I got to the end of my cat,
my thing.
I like two pills left and I was like,
I don't need them.
I'll keep them in case I get hurt again,
some point,
you know.
And um,
fortunately I had them because I was like,
dude,
like this,
that,
that pain that you're going through when you get on a plane.
Because I was in Japan,
I had busted my foot and then I had to fly 16 hours and my foot was swelling on
the plane,
the pressure of high altitude,
it was miserable.
It started in my,
in my,
in my foot and my ankle and it's swollen up into my Shin and calf all the way
down into my toes.
But it was so,
I was like,
that's,
I don't want that to happen to you.
So like,
like,
it's going to be miserable,
but just take this with you and take a pill,
you know?
Um,
he,
he just took one pill.
He said it was a great feeling.
It helped with the help with the flight.
I got ahold of some of that old school nyquil back when day.
I've only taken it like maybe two or three times ever in my life,
but the last time I got some was like 20 years ago,
I took some,
I was sick and I took old school nyquil and I was lying in bed and it was like
my,
my bed was just hugging me.
My bed was made out of love and it was just hugging me and I was like,
ah,
I didn't give
a fuck about that cold.
I was just so relaxed.
Like old school.
NYQUIL's amazing.
I remember that.
I own,
that's coding right,
isn't it?
I think coding was a Nyquil ooze.
Nice man back in the day.
Um,
Tito Ortiz.
I,
I called Tito at one point because I was real sick.
I had a fight coming up too,
and I was like,
man,
I don't,
I don't know what to do.
He's like,
here's what you do.
You take three packs a theraflu and you put that in one cup of water.
Right?
So,
so he's like,
you boil it,
you boil the water and you pour that and you put three facts.
Type Theraflu went there.
I was like,
um,
I,
I started to do it and I was like,
man,
Tito is a light heavyweight.
That's a good move.
I'm glad you did that.
I'm trying to go to,
cause I was out for 18 hours.
I laid down,
I woke up and I still,
I felt like I,
I just don't want to get up.
And I slept.
I slept for,
I was in bed for 18 hours.
I did wake up feeling better though.
Like I would imagine you probably weren't thinking about the cold at all.
No.
So the stress was gone and you're getting that rest.
You're out cold.
I know I was laid out.
I was one of the biggest it,
that's one of the best arguments for like cold medicine is that they let you go
to sleep.
Like if I'm sick and miserable,
I can't fucking sleep.
Yeah.
But if you take something and you just fucking Theraflu is a good one,
you just,
it cleans you out.
Like you could breathe and just calm the fuck out.
And,
and isn't that when you,
um,
what does this chamber,
that old school night call it had a pseudoephedrine Annette,
which is what is used to make math.
Oh Jesus.
Math keep you up.
Yeah.
It doesn't mean any sense.
A stimulant says sudafed.
I got to Google what it was.
This is what,
yeah,
but sudafed is not nyquil.
That's very different.
Sudafeds a stimulant sudafed to the stuff that cleans your nose out.
Right,
right.
This is what doing like what,
how to pseudoephedrine Oh,
the reason why I called the original green death formula Nyquil's behind the
pharmacy counter now because gasp,
it has the evil pseudoephedrine it.
Oh,
so you can buy that shit still.
Some people were looking at,
I was finding an article someone was looking for it in New York.
That's 2013.
I got to get a good doctor.
Might be able to find some stuff.
Interesting.
That stuff fucks you up.
You go deep with that stuff.
I think it's the chemical that it's mixed with the pseudoephedrine is probably
what keeps you alive.
Coding.
What's the drag you down into the grave.
The pseudoephedrine shit keeps you alive.
That's the thing about about sleeping though,
right?
That's when,
um,
when your body,
everything else is off to all your body can do is,
is,
is heal.
You know what else happens man.
You make good decisions like that term sleep on it.
That's not a joke.
Yeah.
There's something about going to sleep with a problem,
waking up in the morning and you have a new perspective.
Like,
Hey,
it's not that big a deal.
Our ads,
all right,
I don't care.
Or you know,
or maybe I should do something about this or maybe I should apologize.
Maybe I should,
you know something about sleeping on something.
I don't know what it is,
man,
but it gives me a truer compass as to which direction I should go.
There's a thing about that too.
There's,
I'm sleeping on it.
I,
I had to teach myself some things about like car mechanics and I,
I had a problem,
but it's somebody who's like,
that's your alternator.
It like,
what?
Cause my engine wouldn't stay on,
you know,
it was like,
really?
It's like how much does that cost?
And I was broke.
That was in,
I was just fighting,
you know,
it was,
there was no UFC even on the horizon yet.
Um,
and I'm,
I'm like,
how much that cost as like too much shit.
I was like,
he's like,
I can do it for you.
And he's like,
you can do it.
And it's like,
how are you going to,
I was like,
I can't afford that either,
but if you can do it,
I'll figure it out.
So I went to the store,
I was like,
Hey,
I need to buy an alternator for this,
this model car.
They were like,
okay.
They bring it out and they're like,
they weren't going,
they weren't going to give it to me cause you have to give them the other one
back.
You have to exchange it.
Really?
Yeah.
Like at least this is the way it was in like 2000 Texas,
you know?
So,
um,
but fortunately one of the managers that that store was,
one of my students is right across the street from my gym.
So I was like,
he was like,
here you can take it,
just bring the alternator back.
I was like,
awesome.
Because I didn't know what an alternator was.
My plan was to grab it,
go look in my engine and said like,
fine,
this is fine.
The like thing,
right.
So that's what I did.
I found the like thing,
I put it in there.
Oh,
I changed it.
I took the other one back,
but I couldn't get the belt on.
I did everything that I was trying to do everything and somebody who's like the
tensioning bolt and I was like,
I don't know what you're talking about.
And I slept on it.
I went to bed that night.
I went to sleep and I woke up,
ran downstairs,
connected it,
you know like I cause overnight.
But there was something about being relaxed and not being like stressed about
trying to find it.
Right now it's right in front of me.
I'm just away from it and I see the whole engine in my sleep and it's like you
put the ratchet in there and you pull on it and that's,
that's the tensioning bolt.
I have a crazy spiritual idea about that.
I think when you go to sleep,
you go into the spirit world.
When you come back you're refreshed.
I think you live a new life every morning.
Thank you.
Live on the momentum of your past life.
But I think you have a new life every morning you just returned from the spirit
world with the mess that you left behind and you got to clean it up,
clean it up and figure it out and like,
oh yeah,
I should have just cranked it bolt over there.
Okay.
It all makes sense.
There's something to that cause I got some stuff going on now where I'm just
like,
when I wake up the next day and I'm like,
you know what,
it's not that big of,
it's not that big of a deal.
Yeah.
Most things are not that big of a deal.
If you're still alive and you're walking around and talking,
ultimately it's not that big of a deal.
Like I give things like the 10 year test,
like if you look back on 10 years,
how much of a big deal it was just going to be not that big of a deal.
Yeah.
It was fucking alternator.
That big of a deal at 10 year test is a good test.
Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
But people
operate on momentum.
That's a big problem with people.
You know,
like when you go to bed,
you wake up in the morning,
you'd,
you still got this shit that you left behind the day before piling up bills you
gotta pay and chores you get to do and all these different tasks that need to
get done.
Like fuck.
You know,
like you can't never get behind it.
It's,
it's,
it's a good day when when he feel like,
okay,
everything's done and like this day is completely mine.
Yeah.
Man,
that's fucking,
that's to to to have like a clean slate in your mind in terms of things you need
to do.
There's no way to underestimate that.
That's giant.
You can't underemphasize how important that is.
Yeah.
Or overemphasized rather.
I completely agree with that is um,
I'm one of those guys who my brain,
I feel like as soon as I wake up first thought leads into the next and to the
next and you,
you,
you can't stay ahead of it and not staying ahead of it.
You're,
you're kind of being dragged along,
being pulled by these thoughts and all these different directions.
Especially when I'm trying to organize some things.
Sometimes I,
if I don't have a list or something like that,
I'm not going to get,
if I have five things to do,
let me get one thing done.
If I don't have a list,
you know,
what changed a lot of my life.
I started working out early in the morning.
My,
my day almost always starts out.
Today's one of the rare days where it didn't,
like today I'm going to work out after the podcast,
but most days I get up in the morning and I work out and the only reason why I
didn't do it today is because everyone in my house is sick.
Everyone and I wanted to get some sleep.
Yeah.
My kids are little petri dishes,
man.
They're just always sick.
Everybody's sick.
So I'm,
I'm the only one so far that's been able to fight it off.
And I woke up yesterday and I'm like,
Ooh,
I got a sore throat like it's coming.
And I fought it off yesterday and I fought it off to,
I got in the sauna,
chilled out.
But something changed in my life.
When I started working out in the morning,
my thought process became clearer.
It May,
it makes more sense because I clean out my mind when I workout.
So I get up in,
the first thing I do is just go work out and clean up my mind.
My mind gets cleaned up on my body's like fully,
uh,
elevated in terms of like,
my heart rate got jacked up.
I'm sweating like a pig.
I already strained already pushed,
already got over some shit already made it to the end and then so there's
already a victory by the time it's,
you know,
8:00 AM yeah.
That,
that to me like then my day just starts off way better.
Like I start off with a clear perspective.
Yeah.
I guess it's similar when I,
especially when I was fighting because you woke up,
get a run in,
eat something,
head to the gym,
you know,
and then you train now that especially run fasted.
Yeah.
I like,
I would,
that would be the first thing I did.
I brushed my teeth and go for a run.
You know,
I,
I didn't,
I didn't like eating anything.
This is when you were living in
Texas.
This is whenever like,
even to this day when I run like,
especially especially in Texas because in the summer
you got to go early before it turns into a barbecue outside.
Exactly.
What I was gonna say is in Texas,
your d mostly flat.
It's mostly flat.
Especially,
especially in Houston.
Austin has some hills,
but Houston is there.
They're the,
the only hills in Houston or the overpasses on.
But now they're out here.
Man.
There's some ferocious trails you can run.
Yeah,
there is a,
there was a hill on my street that's,
I'm a quarter mile.
Oh,
that's miserable.
Yeah.
This is a miserable shit in the Hollywood hills.
Like,
whoa.
Yeah.
If you wanted to get at the bottom and do some sprints going up,
it,
that's so good for your knees too,
because you know,
you're not really a stomping down.
You know,
you're,
you're pushing,
you're pushing up.
So it's just,
it's basically like doing a bunch of lunges.
Yeah.
You feel it in your ass,
dude.
My ass is way bigger than it used to be.
It looks good.
There was a,
there was a,
there was a drill.
Went and I did this a couple of times.
Um,
you,
they would incline the treadmill to the,
to its peak and then turn it up to like 12 or 10 or 12 and you're sprinting for
like 15 seconds.
That was miserable.
I would,
you'd feel that really,
really hard.
I had to wait until you fall off.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or how do you get off that fucking thing where you're sprinting?
You got to grab the edges and hop.
Did you know and I just started using the other day.
It's a motherfucker.
Is that versa climber?
Yeah.
Oh God.
Damn.
I've never been on it for an extended period of time.
Always in a circuit.
Oh yeah.
I did it in a circuit to the last exercise.
It's miserable.
I was like,
motherfucker,
this thing like you do the first two or three strokes,
so like I can get through this and then you're like 10 and you're like,
oh shit.
You like how much time I got left,
a minute and 10 seconds.
How's that possible?
I'm like,
I am not going to make a minute and 10 seconds of this.
It feels weird because like with every stroke it doesn't,
it doesn't,
it's not heavy or hard to make the stroke.
It feels like it's nothing.
But you're also going nowhere,
just like you have,
you're making this motion and I don't know,
read the shit.
You know,
you're like down here like this.
Like how much?
Like how is that possible?
I've only been doing this for 15 seconds.
I get what I like that.
And um,
there's a thing called the echo bike that rogue makes that I have out here.
Holy Shit,
it's an air dyne but it's like an airdyne built for gorillas.
Like if you're gonna put an air dime machine into fucking gorilla cage,
you'd would make like this robot,
it's like thick ass fucking steal thing with thick ass handles.
Everything's like super beefy and jacked up.
God Damn,
that thing kicks you out and show me that.
I want,
Oh,
try it.
It's the Shit,
man.
It's the shit.
I do two bottles on that,
so I'll do twenties and tens 20 seconds work ten second break.
Fuck.
It's fucking hard man.
Those airtime machines look.
So they look and like nothing.
That's one of those things where you look at it,
you're like how
can that be hard?
Yeah.
It,
it's hard to,
when you,
when you alternate,
you know what I mean?
So you're riding them both together,
but you're doing a conditioning workout and coach is standing right there and
eat.
You take your feet off of the panels and you're pumping with your arms.
That's miserable.
Miserable as fuck.
And I also don't,
not that I don't like it,
but one of the in the conditioning workouts,
the parts that were so hard and then kind of draining that I'm,
I don't know what you call it,
but it's with the hydraulic presses.
Oh that's miserable too because every direction there's no rest on that machine.
There's none.
It's kind of crazy when you go back and look at like old school strength and
conditioning workouts at fighters used to do and you know,
comparison to what all the crazy shit that guys do today.
Who,
which,
which camp?
Well it's an argument,
but which camps?
I'll go camp cause I feel like there's two,
which camps really started that,
that,
that the conditioning thing.
Who are ahead of the game?
I was thinking of Att,
I always think of them cause they were like when Lambert created that place,
Dan Lambert,
the fucking man,
that guy,
that guy has done a lot for MMA and he doesn't get his horn blown enough.
Yeah.
He had to respect,
uh,
he uh,
he put a shit ton of money and an American top team and one of the things that
they did about it was make it a full,
like they have everything.
They have great wrestling coaches,
great striking coaches,
great Jujitsu,
huge facility,
everything state of the art.
And I was felt like those guys were out of very high level early on.
Like I remember Tiago Alvarez was making weight this back when like Tiago
Alvarez Garrell law.
Remember how big he was at one 70.
And man when he fought Matt Hughes and he didn't make the weight and he looked
like he weighed about 400 pounds.
He didn't even look like a human man.
He was so jacked.
Well,
he was making weight once and it was a fight that they did.
I think it was at the hard rock.
I don't remember.
Um,
but it was somewhere where they had,
maybe it was at the palms somewhere where they had like the smaller ring,
I think,
I don't know why I remember this,
but what I remember was he was warming up for that day's fight.
Um,
he had made weight and then,
um,
after making weight they had a workout that they would do to put weight back on
him.
And one of the things that they would do was really burned him out.
So they had him,
he was in the gym.
I wish he was here.
I could ask him exactly what this was.
Cause I'm talking many years ago and he goes through this really hard pad
workouts like that.
Bam,
Bam.
I got Bam Bam.
And there they were saying they wanted a pump,
everything up full of blood and then they fill them up with carbs and it would
just,
everything would blow back up.
So like the muscles get super dehydrated cause he's draining himself out big
time.
You know,
he was walking around north of 200 pounds,
cutting down to one 70 and then after the weight cut
they would swell them back up again.
So he got to put 30 pounds back on them in 24 hours.
And that was one of the methods that they used was exercise followed by fuel.
I guess a,
it kind of makes sense and it also confuses me because it confused me too
because I'm a dummy and I was listening to him talking about this.
I was like,
okay,
why is this like what's happening?
How are you doing this?
I get the principle that you're saying but what's the science behind?
Right.
Cause that's where I'm at.
Science.
He looks like a gorilla when he fights and he really put that weight back on.
Well and they had glace in and nobody is bigger at one 55 in glace and t bow.
Yeah,
glaze and tee ball.
It looks like a fucking light heavyweight.
He's so big and somehow or another it makes it down to 55 like when he gets on
the scale it's like you're,
it's like Yoel Romero.
When he gets on the scary,
you're like,
okay,
am I seeing something wrong?
Like how has that one 85 how's that possible?
Yeah,
it doesn't make sense.
Like I'm watching him weigh in.
He is one 85 the guy says one 85 he steps off and you're like,
what in the fuck am I seeing?
How's that possible?
I get that.
Like good t bow.
I've been in the locker room with tee ball a couple of times at att and m but a
t ball.
What are you weighing in right now,
man?
He's like,
oh my friend.
Like one 90 I'm like,
you know one nine to get on the scale.
No,
no.
He don't want to get on the scale.
I'm guarantee use like two 10 get out of here that one night.
He's so big.
He's huge.
Oh look how big he is.
Look at them.
Fucking sad.
I got 155 pounder.
Look at the size of him and eco five eight five,
nine yeah.
Built like a tank.
He's so big.
Do you?
Silly strong dude.
He's the most diesel guide that I've ever seen at one 55 like it,
that is about as thick as it means.
There's no room for error there.
And he made wait a lot.
Yeah.
I mean he might've missed it.
He missed it like once or twice,
but he made most of the time t bow made weight.
He,
it was miserable for him.
Well,
go back to that one picture that you just showed.
Oh,
it's him.
A fighting somebody.
No,
no,
no.
That one right there.
That's um,
track door.
Yeah.
No,
not track door.
no,
no.
Um,
oh God.
Why can't I know who you're talking about?
Brazilian cat Massell room.
What's his crazy and Doula?
Yeah.
What does that crazy nickname?
No,
God damn.
Why can't remember his name?
Same here.
Turn Aldo.
Turn all the functionality.
Yeah.
Toronado far 85 move.
Say Brazil.
Did he fight 85 [inaudible] 80 [inaudible] 85 I believe.
I know he fought Nick Diaz also at 72 crazy.
I feel like,
I don't know if you,
I fought in the UFC at 85 though.
No,
I don't think you did it.
Yeah.
But when you were saying that thing about,
um,
when you said about what you said about att,
I agree,
but I mean even further back than that,
the earliest guys,
frank shamrock was one of the writing shamrock and then the middle and military,
those share mark was the guy really figured out conditioning.
Yeah.
That's how he beat Tito.
Yeah,
for sure.
He was so small in that fight.
He was tiny.
He was like one 95 and Tito was a goal ruler.
He was a big fella.
Yeah.
War is out south.
That was when the weight class was 200 pounds to the,
yeah,
you had to make one 99.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
the early days,
you know?
Yeah.
It was very different back then,
man.
I was,
um,
I was scrolling through fipass watching the whole,
like the entire events.
Then I get down to like 2000 and it gets like,
you scrolling through and it's like 2017 it has all these events across the
screen.
You've got to scroll 16 same thing.
15 starts going down and you get to 10.
It's like it's still less,
but you still got to crawl across the screen.
Then you get to like seven,
you got to like eight and it's like five events,
five events,
five events and that's it.
You know like [inaudible] I have 21 UFC fights under my belt,
but there were five UFC is a year back then it's like now there's like two
months you get like six,
seven,
seven cards.
I just felt like you got fucked and uh,
Josh Thomson,
a lot of guys in your era because they cut out the 55 pound division for a long
time and then you went out and fought up Bodog and all these other
organizations.
There was no 55 for how many years?
Um,
my shoe.
Yeah,
like 2004 to 2000.
2005 to like 2010 for sure.
They didn't come back until,
um,
the ultimate fighter.
Yeah,
like that's when Gilbert and Josh Thompson,
we're having those epic war's over in strike force.
So like those years,
like there was those guys like you Thompson and I feel like Gilbert Gilbert
staked his claim in the UFC and had some epic fights in the UFC.
But I honestly don't think we see the same Gilbert that we saw in strike force.
Yeah,
no,
we,
no one,
no one can say better than you because you've been in there that how much those
wars we'll just take out of you.
They will.
And a guy like,
like the wars that Gilbert and Josh went through it strike force.
And then Gilbert is that kind of guy.
He's just like his fight with the eagles.
That's it.
They're not,
they're not backing down.
And,
um,
they got the chance to take it.
You know,
there's not,
there's not a lot of guys that can,
that can take it like that.
Um,
I haven't been in a lot of wars that,
that we're back and forth.
Even if the,
if the fight had some attrition,
there was a lot of times it was,
um,
I was winning the striking battle and it wasn't taking as many shots as those
guys have taken.
Um,
and they,
you have to have a chin to do that,
man.
Like I couldn't imagine to this day having been in having,
I have like my record shows like 60 something fights.
I have like 80 plus fights overall.
And I still like,
I look at some of those fights like Diego and Gilbert and I'm like,
man,
I'm so glad that Joe,
I remember as a kid I was
laying on my couch watching Vernon white and pancreas and I'm laying there
watching and he's getting his ass beat.
Then it gets to the third round and he turns it around,
knocks the guy out,
right?
And I'm like,
I roll off of the cows,
I get on my knees and I'm like,
God,
please let me have fights like that.
That was the kind of fights that went up.
Please,
please,
please.
I'm like the young kid,
you know,
I just,
I want to do that.
I want to have epic fights like that.
Right.
But now that I'm done and I'm looking back at it,
like there are times I watched that stout fight and when I get hit,
I'm just like,
oh,
it was,
it's,
it's still,
it hurts.
It didn't hurt then,
but like,
it hurts now.
Like I feel like a slight physical pain from it.
Not like it breaks my heart.
It's,
yeah,
that part will always hurt.
But I mean,
like,
that looks brutal.
It's painful.
It's not,
but it looks that way.
But you know,
those fights with Gilbert and,
and,
and like Gilbert and,
and Diego,
when they're still in it,
that shit hurts.
Well,
Gilbert didn't have to fight them that way.
That's why it was so crazy.
It's a,
Gilbert decided to use his skills and find a technical fight.
He would have been,
you know,
he,
he was the better fighter technically at the time,
but he just said,
fuck it.
Let's go to war.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean,
there's just not a whole lot of people that are willing to do that.
Yeah.
That,
that I think that's what it is.
Um,
like Erin,
like my fight with Erin Riley,
um,
I was able to figure him out and I could pick him apart.
So at Aaron is the kind of guy who would go to war with you.
Like if I figured you out,
I'm not going to go like this.
I'm not giving you a chance.
Fuck you.
Right.
You know,
that's why I don't have to prove to anybody else how much of Man I am.
And on the other side of that,
I don't like getting hit.
That shit's nonsense.
That prove how much of a man you are by getting hit.
That's nonsense.
I like when guys like Gilbert choose to go crazy and go to war,
but that's on him.
That's because he wants to,
that is on him.
But you know,
like there's a guy who did something like that and he was willing to go to war,
but you can see he,
he still kept his technique when he went to war.
And I'm talking about Max Holloway when he,
when he,
when he with I'm Ricardo Lamas when he's like right here right now.
He started trading,
but he wasn't just sitting in the pocket trading.
He was throwing his,
getting out,
coming back,
getting up and getting out.
That's how you do that.
You know,
you don't just sit there and go,
okay,
I got mine now.
You get yours now.
Just bite down on that mouthpiece in wing punches.
Yeah,
I mean that's Diego Specialty Diego's the best blood and guts fighter ever.
I mean,
every single fight he's ever had,
his blood and guts.
I would go back to his fight with Martin Kampmann lost the first two rounds.
He's got his face hanging off like literally like a Zombie and he's chasing
after Martin Cameron and he wins a third round.
When's the third round against?
Ellenberger is fighting Ellenberger who was at the time,
you know,
a strong,
powerful one.
70 big punches.
Diego's got his back and the third round he's beating him up.
I mean that's just blood and guts.
That guy's got more blood and guts.
Then virtually a like 99% of the population of the planet earth.
Diego is one of those guys too that he's a scary individual.
When you,
when you look at him as like,
okay that's a potential opponent,
especially in his prime,
but away from that he likes now he's a really,
especially now.
And I was um,
when he fought rigs
like I felt,
I feel like
those two kinds of personalities,
they're just going to be like added at each other all the time.
And you feel like that's how they're going to be always.
But like a guy like Diego,
like look at what he's doing with,
with,
with the guys in,
in Albuquerque is hell,
I forget the guy's name,
but he's helping out that guy that he has a big UFC fan,
the down syndrome,
down syndrome.
I don't remember how old.
That's amazing.
But like,
like he's,
he's committed to this.
It's not like,
it's not like,
and it's not like,
hey check me out.
I'm doing,
you know what I mean?
All the time.
Like he was with the guy all the time.
I like Diego Man.
He's a good dude.
He's a very good dude.
Yeah.
That Rick's fight was crazy too.
Cause rigs never thought the Diego's got Kale stepping in.
Kayla.
And when the right hook like early in the fight too,
it was like,
and rigs is one of those guys that see,
I don't think that he ever totally showed in the octagon what he was capable of
in the gym.
And he also has a guard that peaked during like the kind of like the rich
Franklin Arrow.
You know,
like when he fought Matt Hughes,
didn't he miss wait,
when he fought for the title,
Mr weighed against mad.
He was mad.
He was Kimora Adam and,
but the,
what are the always heard is that Joe rigs in the gym was a world beater.
Like people would spar with them and they'd be like,
Holy Shit.
Like Joe rigs are world champion.
Like he's that good and that he would be Dustin up all these like really high
level guys in the gym.
There's,
there's something though about being in the gym and you know,
you know this button.
The thing that about being in the gym versus being inside the Octagon.
Um,
it's that the stakes are a real now,
like in the gym,
a lot of guys will open up more because you can't really lose there.
You can't,
you know,
but when you're in the fight itself,
you,
um,
you kind of,
you don't want to pull all the triggers because if,
if this bullet misses right,
I'm exposed,
I got no defense to that.
So you're not,
you're not putting everything on the table that you would in the gym because the
risk is so much greater.
And I think that's where,
where are the guys who can perform,
who step up to the game?
I believe that's the aspect that they have to their game,
that that's missing from some of these guys who were world beaters in the gym.
But when they did it,
they just can't bring it to the field.
It's a mental strength for sure.
And it's a confidence and your technique and,
and the,
the outcome.
Some people think that the world's against him.
You know,
there's an attitude that some people have.
Icon never works out for me.
A fucking no more.
I can't catch a break off.
But it's,
it's interesting because those are the guys that can't catch a break and you
always wonder,
he always wonder
what came first,
the chicken or the egg.
Is it the attitude that is making their life this impossible puzzle to solve or
is it they just got,
they just keep getting shitty rolls of the dice are think it's the attitude
probably.
It's like it's a snowball effect from the very first decisions you make real
early on,
especially when competing and you're like,
everybody knows that there's times where you can quit.
Everybody knows there's times where you,
you know,
you didn't train as hard or you didn't push as hard or you didn't.
And some people don't.
Some people don't learn like they have those moments.
Like when you're a little kid and you know,
maybe you're wrestling or something like that and you got scared,
he didn't perform well and then you go back and go,
okay,
that sucked.
I don't want to do that again.
I've got to figure out how to fucking toughen up or I've got to figure out how
to just perform.
And some people just don't date.
Some people just run away from it.
The runaway never ever see that thing again.
Yeah.
It's like there's the weird little moments in fights that you could see
happening where guys are exhausted,
but they dig down.
You know what,
fine.
I always call upon like,
here's a dude who's got impossible mental strength.
Darren Elkins,
Merseyside Tick Merseyside Beck is lightened him up like a Christmas tree in
Times Square.
I mean,
he's just fucking him up.
He is on point.
He looks like a future champion.
He looks fantastic.
Darren Elkins won't stop.
He won't stop.
He keeps going.
He keeps coming.
He's absorbing punches,
he's covered in blood.
He's getting punched and kicked and Shand and fucking elbow keeps coming,
keeps coming,
keeps coming.
Boom.
He catches them.
You see backtick Waba and you're like,
oh no.
Boom,
head kick.
Like what the fuck?
Darren Elkins is pounded them out and then the referee stops the fight and then
can steps off of them is like,
it's like God damn I that is,
that is the reward for having indomitable spirit like that.
That is a,
the kind of victory cry that you only get when you went through hell and you did
not give up.
Yeah.
That,
that fight itself after the second,
I believe it was you just like,
this is like,
they should be stopped.
Right.
This should be stopped.
He's though there's no chance and I don't really watch them get beat up as much.
So,
um,
like tweeting about the fight and watching and I'm looking back and forth and
then holy fuck,
all of a sudden decides upside
down.
I love that guy.
And then Elkins chokes out Michael Johnson.
Man shows people he's got skills.
That's,
that's,
that's the other thing.
There it is right there.
I mean,
we're sod beck.
Dick.
It was super fucking talented,
like just an undefeated coming into this fight.
Daren was covered in blood and he got crucifixed here and he's getting smashed
with punches and elbows.
But elk hunt,
he's just one of those guys.
Darren just doesn't give up.
And the other thing about Messiah is massage.
I've trained Messiah,
Messiah trains hard.
His conditioning earlier that is conditioning is on point.
Look do this.
That's crazy.
That's so crazy.
Yo,
there's another screen like that when cat Zingano beat Amanda Nunez.
Yeah.
It's another one like that.
I don't remember her victory dude.
That one is bone chilling.
You hear the scream,
you're like,
whoa.
Like it gets your hair like I might,
I got goosebumps just thinking about it.
Yeah.
Listen to that
dude.
That meant a lot to her man.
You can hear it.
Yeah.
Dude,
that's some shit you can't fake.
Yeah.
You know,
there's something about what you were saying though about um,
people like walking away from these things.
It's,
it makes me think of like of a kid,
I'm sorry this is,
this is going to be like a bunch of things tied into one thing,
but
babies when they're first born,
like first thing that come out of babies usually cry.
Right?
Right.
And it's like my thought on that is like this is the first time they felt
anything outside of that womb.
Right.
And,
and they don't know what pain is like a pain tolerance.
The first time you got kicked it it,
it hurts a lot more than it does now.
Yeah.
Right.
So like every sensation is new for them.
And then you're growing up and you grow up to be,
these people in your,
your parents are telling you can do anything,
but at the same time they're telling you don't do that.
Right.
So it's like,
like the mind is,
your brain is this,
this is a blank slate when you're born and you get all these different
influences.
And this goes back to the people that are like,
I can't catch a break.
I can't get your break.
It's like,
are we,
are we doing this right?
Because for so many people that have this attitude,
you know,
I'm like,
what,
where,
where is that coming from?
Because it's,
there are so many people like that and then there are people that are like that
at times and then,
but they can,
they can either come out of it and started having good things or,
and then they go back into it and they bounced back and forth.
But why are people the way they are?
Like the Ma,
the human mind to me is like the most amazing,
confusing.
Like ev,
it's everything,
but like there's no rule.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
everybody's different there.
Everybody's similar,
but everybody's different.
And your attitude has a giant effect,
not just on your life but on other people's lives around you.
That's the other thing about it.
Those,
I can't catch a break guys.
Get them the fuck away from me.
I can't,
I can't be around those guys.
I don't want to hear that shit.
I don't buy it because everybody has bad brakes.
Yeah.
I've had a shit ton of bad breaks,
but you know what I did?
I stayed up and I thought through it and I figured out what the fuck I did wrong
and then I went back.
It's like I fucked up everything I've ever done a hundred times.
There's no way to other,
there's no other way to do it and I've had a bunch of shitty breaks everybody,
but you got to realize
when you have those shitty breaks,
what that is,
it's an opportunity for you to reassess,
reboot,
get better,
figure out another way,
find another way through.
It's,
this is just a little challenges and the people that look at those challenges to
gold,
one whoa does have its challenges,
their cancer,
those people are dangerous to be around.
They will rob you of your enthusiasm.
They don't give you any fuel that the opposite of fuel,
the fuel people there,
the whole,
the people that are kicking ass,
the people that are out there just fucking hustling,
always,
always getting things done.
It got like my friend Jocko every morning I'll check his Instagram page for 30
shows,
a picture of his watch.
Get after it.
He's out there working out four 30 in the morning.
He does it every fucking morning.
Why?
Because,
cause he doesn't want to and that's how you do it.
You go and get after it.
You don't make any excuses and those kind of guys are fuel.
But those,
I can't catch a break guys.
They're the opposite of fuel.
They just pissing on your fire.
They're no fun.
And though,
and then the people that surround them are all idiots because only idiots want
to be around.
I can't catch a break.
Guys owned a dummy stick around after a while.
Even if they're your good friend,
you've got to be like,
Bro,
you got to fucking stop.
You've gotta stop with all this.
I can't catch a break.
Bullshit all the time.
Your complaining.
You could be instead hustling.
You could be instead chasing your dream.
You could be instead figuring out what you're doing wrong,
trying to improve certain aspects of your life,
getting your shit together,
reading a book,
meditating something,
fucking something.
But this,
I can't catch a break.
Shit is not helping anybody and it pushes everybody away from you.
But some people they get caught in that pattern and it might be their parents.
It might be how they were raised.
Somebody might've told him they were useless real early on.
It's stuck and they just,
they always,
they never feel like they get enough reassurance.
They never feel like they get enough motivation and they feel like other people
get more and they look at all these other people who commute to hook them.
She gets this,
how come he's got that going on and that all that's bad for you too.
That shit ain't no good for you.
How much of that is tied into not paying attention to yourself?
Not,
not knowing yourself,
you know how much time,
how much of that is his time as tuned into a,
tied into you always on your brain,
always outside of yourself.
You,
you've flushing,
you're flooding your brain with TV or Instagram or you know,
and not,
not something that even even reading a book I believe is,
is different.
Oh,
when you're watching TV,
what you're watching,
you know what I mean?
If you're watching something that,
that has a message where you have to think where you,
you can see yourself in that and you can put yourself in these situations and
you're like,
oh well that's,
I can empathize with that.
Oh,
I can this.
But when you're just watching,
oh,
spending money on cars and,
and making it rain and this and that,
you know,
um,
and wonder how much of that,
because like the thing and I've found is like entertainment isn't what it used
to be and this,
this is,
I'm going to sound old as shit,
right.
Back in my day,
entertainment entertainment wasn't what it is now.
It's just like
bright lights and flashing bombs.
Right.
Versus like something that you could actually feel.
I feel like it's a lot less of that.
Well,
there's some entertainment that you could feel like TV shows.
Do you watch black mirror that'll freak the fuck out of you or make you think
there's still some good shit that's being made.
The stranger things there's,
and go find it so much more.
Like I feel like the,
the bigger things,
like the things that most people have access to
that I think that's what it is.
Right,
right.
But is it that they have more access to that or is that the easiest thing to
easiest thing to,
to consume?
It's very easy to consume.
It's mindless and everybody wants cars.
Uber,
the car,
everybody wants money.
Look at his money.
You know,
it's like you just get sucked up in it and it's,
it's a very low level frequency that everybody sorta has like a little bit of it
and you see this,
I'm dude with his open shirt,
all these chains and it's always girls behind him and their underwear.
Everybody's dancing.
It's like this guy's life's a party.
My life is a party.
I can't catch a fucking break.
I'm over here.
A current character work.
It's cool.
It's,
it's cool sometimes,
you know,
sometimes it's silly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because there's a point like,
you know,
who's,
who's a deep guy fucking chilling and Shell is very deep and he,
he,
he pointed this out to me through a different way,
but there's a point where everything becomes a bad thing.
There's a point where like humility is,
is a,
is a bad thing.
There's a point where I'm having fun as a bad thing.
It's like you can't,
you can't,
like eating does,
it isn't always a pleasure if you,
if you're constantly eating,
if you're never hungry,
you don't appreciate it as much as if you are hungry.
Because if you're,
if you're starving and they feed you and you can start you,
you're full and you have to keep eating,
that's not fun.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's this moderation thing that I feel that's missing and I'm trying to find
that balance with myself,
man,
with what?
With life with,
with the bunch of different things,
um,
with,
with how much time I spend doing this versus this.
Especially now that I'm not fighting because that,
that was for a long time.
That was the biggest part of my days.
You know,
just just training and everything else and now I still get to train,
but I have more time and a lot of time by myself in my own head.
So I'm back to reading and listening.
Schilling,
the guard that exposed that crimes kid for being a racist and his family was all
written.
Then his mother said something like contacted shilling about keeping money in
the Wa with the whites or some shit.
Yeah,
Joe was,
Joe reached out because he wanted to,
he wanted to know,
want to like bring the kid out or training or something.
Go tour event.
The kid,
the kid,
it was a a viral,
we shouldn't pull the kid up to Jones.
He's a little kid.
He's,
you know,
I don't feel like we should give the kid anymore exposure.
It's not because the kid didn't do anything wrong,
right.
He was just crying them up,
kind of bullied and everybody was like,
oh,
this poor kid,
you know.
Now,
I don't,
I don't know this,
the part of,
of his part in the,
the bullying thing,
but what we're talking about his,
his,
his mom's conversation with Joseph and that's where it got like,
that's where it got twisted.
It was that proven that was his mom would definitely wasn't someone trolling,
I don't know.
Everything is fucking a mystery today.
Up is down,
down is up as a lot of trolls out there,
man.
I'm not,
I feel like,
I feel like there's been,
there's been reports that it was and they,
and was reports that it wasn't and I didn't pay so much attention to it that I
could be like positive as to what,
what the ruling was put.
Um,
the conversation that she had with Joe was Joe reached out to bring him out and
um,
she was like,
look,
I'm just trying to put some money in this account basically.
And um,
Joe is like,
Hey,
I'm trying to give him something more valuable than money.
And um,
she said something she wanted something else gofund gofundme.
And then there was something else Joe said like what's the money going to like,
you can't cure bullying with money.
Yeah,
but I forgot how it turned to some racial spend.
The money within the whites.
Yeah.
It was something,
something along those lines but don't,
I don't know.
Like,
like why did she even bring that up?
Like what in Joe's contacts made her go to that card.
Why dude shaped head covered in tattoos.
She took a chance.
She's like white power,
white power.
She went fishing.
I don't know man.
I mean she made me,
she's just a fucking dummy.
I mean the,
the,
the family is concerned,
a confederate flag shirt and some of their photos that's,
that's still on the flag.
The state flag in Mississippi.
No,
I didn't.
That's crazy.
See that,
that's crazy to me because like I didn't grow up knowing him about that.
Like I like as a kid in The Bahamas,
like I didn't even know,
I knew I came at 15.
Uh,
yeah,
so like,
you know,
the years when everything is being set,
I was in The Bahamas,
in your brain.
So when I got here,
like I still had no idea what the confederate flag was.
A,
I told us people like I didn't know a lot of us history,
you know,
um,
we learn Bahamian history and The Bahamas.
And when I got here I didn't know anything about that.
The confederate flag didn't mean anything to me until I was in my twenties man.
Wow.
And,
and in Texas to this day,
my daughter where she lives,
warehouses maybe like four miles away,
I was visiting and they're there on the corner with a trailer out and they've
got like confederate flags for sale,
for sale on the corner just lining up.
They have them out,
you know,
just line up a flying.
People still drive around.
I was in Florida with Dustin and Numb,
we were driving and there was a truck with a US flag posted on the back.
And confederates with not,
not like posted on the car.
I mean,
when a flag pole flying the flag pole as they're driving.
So this is a real thing.
You love the south.
The south needs a new flag.
You can't have a flag.
I got no problem with you.
Love in the,
the south
got a lot of great quality.
Know you guys need a new flag.
You can't have the flag of the dudes who are fighting for slavery.
You can't have that anymore Joe.
They weren't fighting for slavery.
Yeah.
They,
that argument is a piss poor argument.
It falls apart.
That argument is one of the shittiest arguments and people try to,
they try to like soldier up and use big words and try to repackage that
argument.
They wanted slavery period.
They're fighting for economics.
Yeah.
Slavery.
They wanted people to work for free.
That's like a big part of what it was.
There was a lot of other shit going on as well.
That was a big part of it.
That was a huge part of it.
And I mean it's,
it's representative in the laws that came right after slavery was abolished.
Did you know that there's a reason why,
you know,
when people think about people from the south,
people think of them as being like slack,
jawed and kind of stupid.
That's like the worst stereotype.
Right?
Right.
Southern people knew her,
Yo,
dude.
Yeah.
There was a hookworm epidemic in the south for years where a substantial portion
of the population had hookworm where they were walking around barefoot and they
got shit in their fee and those parasites infected their brain and compromise
the way they think and severely diminishes your,
your level of thinking.
So does that,
um,
pull that shit up,
Jamie does that,
that came up out of a podcast,
right?
Didn't someone bring it up to us?
I feel like it was Rhonda Pat.
No.
Was it Rhonda?
Someone like that.
Some smarty pants.
When that happens,
um,
does that,
does that well,
however that affects your brain.
Does that pass on it?
You know what I'm getting questions like,
is your low change your DNA?
I bet it does.
I bet everything changes your DNA.
Here it goes.
How a worm gave the south a bad name.
Here it is.
Make the shit a little bigger.
Uh,
for more than three centuries,
a plague of unshakable,
lethargic blanketed the American south.
It began with ground itch,
a prickly tingling in the tender webs between the toes soon followed by a dry
cough.
Weeks later,
victim succumb to an insatiable exhaustion and an impenetrable haziness of the
mind that some called stupidity.
Adults neglected their fields and children grew pale and listless victims
develop grossly distended bellies and angel wings.
A macerated shoulderblades accentuated by hunching all gays doubt Deli from
sunken sockets with a telltale fisheye stare.
The culprit behind the germ of laziness of the south's affliction was sometimes
called,
was nick k tore Americana's the American murderer.
Wow.
Better known today as the Hookworm,
millions of those blood sucking parasites lived,
fed,
multiplied,
and died within the guts of up to 40% of the population.
Stretching from southern southeastern Texas to West Virginia.
Hooks warms stymied development throughout the region and bread stereotypes
about lazy,
Moronic southerners.
So where do you as you're reading that,
fuck yeah,
that's gross.
I remember learning about hookworms as a kid in The Bahamas,
but I,
as you're reading that,
I'm like,
you know what?
Maybe this is,
I go through this whole thing in my brain as you're reading.
Maybe if they didn't do what they did to native Americans because those guys had
moccasins and they probably had magazines because they learned about this a
couple of hundred years ago.
You know what I mean?
No Shit.
Right.
If anybody was going to be barefoot,
it'd be the native American.
Right.
And they were like,
no dog.
Not a good move.
Got To cover your feet,
man.
It's been shit gets in there and get stupid and can't figure out how to find the
buffalo anymore.
That's where,
that's where that's sharing information comes in handy,
man.
That's a good point.
That's a real good point.
Cause I always think that when I see that all those survivor dudes,
I like to walk around barefoot.
It was crazy dudes to get the thick calluses and the bottom of their feet and
their idea is that,
you know like,
hey,
if the world goes to shrimp,
you're going to need to be able to walk barefoot.
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense.
Maybe.
Maybe you make shoes,
you fuck,
you know there's a bunch of shoes and warehouses the world.
Yeah,
exactly.
How,
how would you run out of shoes?
I mean,
if you just,
if you found it,
the world was gonna End,
you bought 20 pairs of shoes that might last you two,
you're dead.
Yeah.
Maybe it depends on what you're doing.
What kind of hiking.
You're running a lot.
Burn through those.
You gotta you're going to have to be on your feet more because you got hunt now.
That's true.
You're going to have to be hiking.
Yeah.
Maybe you need more than 20 you don't need more than 50 50 pairs of shoes.
Probably repurpose them to,
yeah,
but that's what the native Americans did,
right?
Yeah.
They,
they,
they used every piece of the Buffalo.
Yeah.
You know,
they were smart too because they didn't develop,
like I'm a,
I'm a on this barefoot running kick.
I run with barefoot shoes.
I either run with those Vibram five fingers,
which are my favorite,
but when it gets muddy out there,
those don't have a lot of traction.
And I liked this other company called Vivo Barefoot.
Plus they don't,
you don't look as Dorky.
The VI,
the five fingers ones you're committing to the project,
right?
You got to walk around with gloves on your feet.
People mock you mercilessly.
Like Jamie,
he mocks me mercilessly.
But uh,
the Vivo barefoot wants to just like,
they just have no padding but they have good traction's.
I like running in those too.
But when you run in something that has no padding at all,
you do all the muscles in your foot develop cause that your toes have to work
and push.
Whereas like these things,
these things are way stiffer than what I run with most of the time.
These things are hard,
man.
It's like a cast.
Like this shit is like a cast for your foot,
you know?
And so the idea is when your foot is in those kinds of like a normal running
shoe,
it's not really squishing and pushing and you're all,
your muscles aren't getting activated and so they're just not as strong.
They just,
they're just weaker,
you know,
and that it's not good for anything.
It's not good for,
your balance is not,
it's not optimum.
I mean it's better to run with running shoes on then,
not Ron,
but in terms of like foot strength and like just maximize your ability to move
correctly and have good balance.
It's not nearly good.
It's,
it's,
you can feel it too.
Um,
when I first started doing MMA for a long time,
until I went down to Florida and was at American top team,
there were certain things that I didn't do without shoes on.
Like if we were kickboxing,
I would put on shins and I would wear my wrestling shoes really?
How come?
Um,
I just didn't like wrestling without my toes out like that,
you know?
Especially when I was throwing kicks,
right.
Not,
but,
um,
over time I got more comfortable with it,
but over time getting more comfortable with it,
I could feel the difference when I would have my shoes on versus not having my
shoot.
Um,
yeah.
Versus not having my shoes on and it's,
I had,
I felt more decks Darrius I felt more agile.
It felt more in connection with,
you know?
Yeah.
When I was doing,
yeah.
That's legit.
That's a,
I mean that's what I do with these barefoot running shoes.
I mean,
I believe in him 100%.
I think there's a bunch of good companies that make them Morel make some good
ones too.
Um,
but I just feel like we have too much padding on our shoes.
You're,
you're,
I w I lift weights and do everything else totally barefoot.
I just feel like a,
or are we are like,
I like chucks,
converse all stars.
Yeah,
those are good too.
because they don't,
they're just flat,
you know?
Those are good for lifting weights sometimes if I want like a little bit more,
but most of the time I do it barefoot.
I would say 99% of the time I do it barefoot.
It's just,
I think it's just better for your feet,
you know?
I just think I'm the same thing when I was saying with gloves and punching,
I've saying it's unnatural.
It's unnatural to have a bunch of shit underneath your foot.
Your foot is not designed for that.
Yeah.
When you,
when you say that,
I start thinking about,
um,
how people I design and where people are designed for and then write thoughts
and they go everywhere.
Sometimes my thoughts like run into another,
hey,
that's a good idea.
Like he come together.
Right?
Um,
but when you say that,
I started thinking about when we talk about changing your Dna,
where we started with the hookworm thing,
um,
and your feet,
if you take someone from an area that is where they have to be agile and you
take them to a place where you just have to be strong,
you take a child from,
from the Agile area and you make him grow up in a strong area,
in an area where you have to be strong,
physically strong.
Does,
um,
how does that child fear in that environment as he's going up,
does he adapt?
Not as fast as the people that already have those traits,
but does he adapt and be able to survive?
And then can he go back to that,
to,
to the agile lifestyle and with,
and take some of that strength?
Depends on how many,
how big
he gets.
You know,
like if you were talking like strong man strength,
those guys are not known for their agility right there.
Giant.
You know,
there's,
there's a trade off for sure.
There's a power trade off.
You know,
that's one of the things it's so terrifying about Francis in Ghana is that he's
270 lbs.
Cuts down to two 65 but he moves like a,
right?
It's like he's not missing anything.
Like,
you know what I mean?
He's got ridiculous power,
but he's also fast as fuck.
Like that left hook that he hit over him with.
It's like Jesus,
that's like a welterweights left hook,
fat as fuck.
But he's hitting you like a nuclear weapon.
It's just a different kind of power on his punches,
a different kind of power in his body.
But he also has the ability to move fast,
like a smaller person.
Most of the time when you get a really powerful person,
there's some sort of compromise.
It has to be made,
right?
And,
but what have you take?
What happens when a guy like Francis and Gansu you develop his wrestling so that
it's like a Cain Velasquez.
Did you though at 33 like that's,
that's the problem.
Yeah.
I like,
you know,
and how much does he,
does he not like to wrestle?
Because that was the word that I had heard is that he wasn't doing any
groundwork.
It was very little groundwork being done.
They were just trying to keep the fight standing.
The problem with that is you can't just do what you like to do.
You can't just do what you're awesome at.
He's already awesome it putting people in another dimension.
Yeah.
I mean he hits harder than anybody I've ever seen.
I've never seen anybody that hits his heart is Francis and Ghana and that's that
power cube thing shows it.
I mean,
he got the highest registered punched Tyrone spawn was number two.
His Punch was something like 10,000 pounds more power or more than,
than Tyrone spawns,
which is crazy.
He's a machine to be allowed to hit people.
He's a monster.
He's so powerful.
But it's like all things balance out,
right?
Like Steve Paige just said,
Yep,
you're powerful for about five minutes and I'm not going to be there for those
five minutes.
I'll be over here and I'll be over here and I'll be ducking and getting the fuck
away from you.
He took a few,
it takes a guy like Steve Bay that can,
is smart and fight smart and knows the game,
like knows like you can't keep this up with cane,
be able to do the same thing name you would expect.
So it cane young Kane for sure.
Like the cane to fuck check Congo.
The cane have fought.
Um,
Ben Rothwell that cane,
she's just Christ that came,
could have done that to anybody.
But I think what you deal with with Kane was like a mental strength that no
one's body can hold up to.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like he just drove forward with so much tenacity that his body is like,
tires are flying off and bolts are breaking and it's just too much strength in
the mind.
When you say that I picture,
I see it in my head and I picture him moving forward a lot.
Like no Manga met off and lose a lot just with better striking and what people
keep forgetting.
Never go.
Madoff was injury written as well.
He was constantly plagued with a lot of guys at Ey.
Hey,
you know I had three or four of my UFC fights because Josh Thompson got hurt.
You know,
I can think of,
I can think of off the top of my head.
Two of them were where it was because Joshua was hurt and they,
what do you think about that?
Do you
think that they train too hard or do you think that that is just the way you
have to train if you,
I mean you look at World Class Fighters,
Aka is one of the top gyms in the world.
Luke Rockhold,
Daniel Cormier,
Cain Velasquez,
Josh Thompson,
and you can keep going down the road.
There's a ton of like guys that people haven't heard of that are top level
Neuroma,
Madoff,
obviously ton of guys also that a train and out of there that are super,
super high level.
There's a big fucking tank filled with sharks.
Now do you look at their success and it's just undeniable.
They have incredible ratio of success like world champions,
some of the best guys ever,
but a lot of injuries.
And was that just what happens when you get both things?
I believe especially with those guys were those guys that concern.
It has to do with the number of quality guys that they have that a fighting at
the same time and only they only being so many hours in the day.
So they are in the gym at the same time having to do the work that they need to
do to prepare for a fight.
But they're all on the same.
Matt and guys were running into each other,
right?
It's happening.
So Glueck is over here and Khabib is over here,
but they've got five different guys rotating for them.
And one of those five guys is is the reason that no mag amount of gets hurt?
No,
that's a problem,
right?
Like that doesn't have an,
and you never see worldclass boxers sparring in the same ring as other world
costs bar same time,
same time.
It's stupid.
Yeah.
That's a size issue in terms of the gym size as definitely a thing in that,
in that regard.
Um,
also the,
the layout of the gym,
you know,
like a boxing ring,
you could put them in a quartered off area.
Right.
And nobody else could be involved.
You,
you section off the mats,
but then you have to have coaches in between.
People's will let,
when these guys starting to come together,
the coach comes in,
hey guys who start going back to your area.
You know,
there's,
there's just no,
no borders and without having borders and,
and a guy like Hector Lumbar,
I'd come in after me.
You know,
you're,
you're gonna move.
Yeah.
In a crash into people.
I think that's a real good point.
I think it's the level of talent,
the aggression in the room,
the level of ambition in the room,
all of the above.
And the fact that they have that philosophy to just go hard.
I mean they go hard.
Yeah.
Like I talked to DC about and he's like sometimes Kane and I spar and sometimes
we fight.
Yeah.
I'm like,
God damn.
You know you have a fight before the fight,
like legitimate,
full on,
you know,
fights that happened or shots that happens.
Yeah.
I remember being um,
being underneath t bow trying to come to my feet and he stole big punches with
little gloves on.
Right.
We're wearing a little gloves,
spying and,
and make gloves and he's hitting me and hitting me in the face like three times
and I'm like,
that's entirely too hot.
But if I don't get up,
he's just going to keep going.
Right.
But like that's what it is,
man.
When you're in the gym there some guys that they just,
they just,
they only have one speed and a lot of those guys are the guys that could perform
when it's time to step into the cage.
You know,
who does the story?
Tj Dillashaw,
all the Alpha male guys were saying that Tj,
when he was bar would spar real hard and then when you would hurt him he tried
to kill you.
Yeah.
You know just how we go.
But look,
it's a fucking world champion for a reason to time.
You know that that tenacity,
you know,
that makes you a sometimes a problematic sparring partner.
That same mental strength and who knows who's telling the truth because this is
obviously alpha male.
They were a little salty after he left and you know,
I don't think they're lying,
but I think there's two,
two sides of the story.
There's two sides of the story.
And there's also,
you know,
people accentuate their position.
Yeah.
I mean if you get,
if you watch a video versus hearing two people,
they'll a story,
right?
You see three different things.
Yeah Man,
I've had people tell me things like,
man,
you won't believe what happened.
And then I watched the video.
I'm like,
wait a minute.
What did you think you saw?
Cause I didn't see that.
I saw it.
I saw something pretty reasonable.
But when these guys go back and watch fights and they're like,
I won that flight.
Yeah.
Like,
no you didn't.
That's a real problem.
Yeah.
Look,
some,
some people,
and again those are really the same guise as the,
I can't catch a break guys.
The ones who think they won when no one else thinks they won Washington like,
hey man,
what fight are you watching?
Like you definitely didn't win.
Look at your,
but your face.
Yeah,
the fucking judges man.
That that is really the number one problem.
If all the rules,
all of these different things,
those are all problem.
The judges or the biggest problem by far,
like every,
it seems like every UFC,
I'm waiting to interview the fighter.
I'm in the cage in there reading the scorecards and I just go like every UFC
it's like one fight at least while I'm like,
what?
What the fuck did they just say 30 27 who?
How what?
Like it guys getting their asses kicked,
taken down,
getting fucked up on the feet and they're winning rounds.
30 27 yeah.
Ten nine,
ten nine ten nine.
What the,
I've seen that I saw,
I saw a fight recently.
I can't remember what it was,
but when,
when the judging came up,
I heard 30,
27 and I was like,
there was no guarantee that any guy won any of those.
Oh,
sorry.
There was a guarantee when I heard 30,
27 I thought this guy one because I'm like,
he won that round.
So they thought he will know that too,
you know?
And then they gave it to the other guy and I'm like,
how does that,
how did he lose that one round?
It's full incompetence,
man.
It's just fallen competence.
Is it,
what is it like now when you are,
you're working for UFC and you're doing the Fox stuff like Fox coverage of UFC,
um,
d do you,
do you have like a set schedule?
Like how often do you guys do it?
Um,
so there are like seven,
actually there were seven when I started.
I think there are more guys now in that rotation and um,
you don't have a set schedule.
Um,
so they just call you up,
hey,
Thursday.
Well they give it,
they give it to you a few weeks out yet.
Plenty of advanced notice.
So like the next desk job.
I'm working,
I'm is the Barbosa Lee fight.
Which one is that?
That's on the 21st of April.
April.
Okay.
Oh,
I think that's Atlantic city and hard.
Yeah,
that's a Frankie Edgar's fighting who's hubs once cubs won.
So about that fight.
I don't like to fight.
I don't,
I don't have a problem with it.
Like I feel like Frankie just got knocked out.
Yup.
And that's really soon to come back.
If anybody can bounce back from something like that.
It's a guy like Frankie,
but I felt the same way about Bisbing fighting after he didn't get knocked out
and get dropped by George and they got choked unconscious.
He's like,
yeah,
you shouldn't take that gas.
No fight so soon.
Yep.
Completely agree.
And I feel that way about this flight because I feel like Frankie wants this
fight because he wants to get that taste out of his mouth.
Um,
but like,
it's still going to taste the same.
Anytime you go back and watch that fight,
you still gonna have those feelings,
right?
You,
you're going to win your next fight,
more than likely your Frankie Edgar,
you don't have to rush it.
Like,
let your brain rest recover.
That's how I feel about it.
But that's only because I'm 41.
Now.
If I,
if I was 26,
maybe I would have been,
and I know Frankie's like 32,
33,
36,
[inaudible] 36,
I think he's 36.
Find out for us.
I'm pretty sure Frankie,
36.
But I'm like,
you want to go out there and do it.
But when I think about brain trauma and your things that I forget,
I'm always like my cds flaring up.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
you know,
he fought cub just a couple of years ago in Malden and got a last second
submission.
Maybe he just thinks,
look Danish fucking thing in the world.
This guy can do to stop me.
Yeah.
You know,
I fucked him up before.
I'm going to fuck him up again.
It doesn't matter.
I'm not even going to get hit,
I'm just going to get ahold of them.
Ragdoll I'm just like I did before.
But Cub Swanson King Crack,
he can crack and he's got a kid now and he's got a second kid along the way and
that doesn't quit,
does not quit and that makes dude's hungry.
And that fight is probably a massive motivating factor for the cubs.
And He,
there's a cub is cub is still around and cubs,
he's still number four because he tastes the lessons from these fights.
He learned something in that fight with Frankie.
I can't see that fight going.
I mean there's a part of me that can see that if I go in exactly the same the
same way,
but I can also see cub having made adjustments because of the lessons that he
learned from that or
am noon and he had to learn from the tiger fight as well.
Look at how we're taking a handled Frankie.
He handled him very smart,
very creative,
mean cub fight a different way.
COBB is more of an in and out guy and he explodes on Ya and you know,
he keeps his hands down low and sneak shots on you.
He does a lot of weird shit cubs.
He's real creative.
He's got to watch out for the take down.
And the wrestling control though,
cause that that's a big factor in the fight.
That was giant.
That's where he got controlled.
But I mean it's a great fight.
I just,
again,
I'm just,
I'm just all about what's better,
what's better in the long run,
right.
You know.
Well it's Toms River.
The problem is a New Jersey and this is going to be in Atlantic city and all the
boys are going to come down and yeah,
I'm with you 100% I would like to see this fight,
but I would like to see this fight in six months.
Yeah.
I mean it's a good fight.
It's good funny for a Frankie could walk,
fought Frankie go in there and wipe them out or do exactly what he did last time
or it can be a battle and then nothing comes of it.
But it's just like,
I'm like err on the side of caution and some good fights on this card man.
Yup.
David Branch and Tiago Santos.
I'm the,
I'm looking forward to that one tricky fucking fight that Tiago Santos guy is a
marker that dye that dude crushes people and he um,
ever since has lost the spice Lee.
He's been like,
it seemed more focused.
He's a fucking animal man.
Very dangerous striker and David Branch coming off of that performance against
Luke Rockhold.
He had Brock hold her know he had rock hold her and you know he wound up getting
dominated,
wound up getting mounted and beaten down.
Got his back taken and smashed.
But he learned a lesson in that flight too for sure.
You'll learn a lot about conditioning when you fight.
A guy like Rockhold to Rockhold is one of the best in the division at top
control.
He gets on top of Dude's like what he did with Chris Weidman,
five minutes off stud wrestler.
He gets on top of him and it's like he might as well how to building setting on
him.
He has his body type is,
is,
is something that high to deal with with just how long he is,
but how good he is at Jujitsu and the controls and positioning.
That's a problem man,
when you,
because you have to make that extra effort,
you know,
when you start hip escaping,
um,
and,
and on a regular guy,
the guy that you're comfortable with,
the size,
you know,
you don't have to make as the movements for as long.
But Luke,
his build and the way he is and his understanding of positioning,
that's a hard,
he's a hide out for a lot of guys.
Yeah,
he's got that Heidrick Gracie type body long strong.
It's,
it's,
it's weird.
It's just different.
It's like when I first rolled with like those guys over the,
the judo guys like them Bursey Madigan,
Berrien and Carl and those guys,
I roll with them and it's like there,
they have this Jujitsu style that's like,
the timing is just off of beat somehow and the hitting all these cameras and
it's like,
it's,
it feels funky.
I feel like that's how Rockhold his body has Cody Mckinsey was like that.
Um,
when I thought Cody,
I was like,
I'm really good at escaping
back control and I peel them off and it's like,
fucking,
it's so how much leg do you have?
A,
you know what I mean?
It's just keeps going.
Yeah.
Well that's what makes the Yoel Romero fight all the more impressive that your
Merrill shut that shit down a tire.
Lee.
He's terrifying man.
But he's seen everything,
right?
Like wrestling all the best guys in the world.
Did you see the podcast?
I did with him and Joey Diaz.
I watched some of it and I,
I was,
I like to listen to your stuff when I'm going to bed,
but like,
so it's all in my head sometimes when I fall it,
when I pass out and I was in Texas,
I was driving all the time.
So I would listen.
When I leave,
I leave Austin drive to Houston.
I would hear like two or three episodes because I can go in there and then
coming back I said three hours or two and a half hour drive each way right out
here.
I'm not in the car as much,
so I,
I get,
I get a lot of snippets.
Right.
So I got some of some of the Yeoman mail,
but I haven't got the whole episode.
He was talking about the program,
the rest of the program coming up in it.
What it was like amazing.
Yeah,
I heard,
I heard some of that about how,
um,
you know,
they're on a pyramid and they,
what was it that the top guys,
they get the best.
They get in some of the best food,
the best food,
the best.
They get three meals a day.
The other guy was get to yeah.
Like everything's better and they're all working out with each other all the
time.
So they're all around each other all the time and he's like,
everybody knows you hurt your wrist.
Oh,
everybody knows.
And those are the guys you're going to have to go against.
Yeah.
That,
see that.
See that that is a representation of capitalism.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
It is exactly what it is.
It is capitalism inside of communism.
Yeah,
no,
yeah.
But key people poor and hungry and like the best in the world,
the best they can do is get three meals a day.
Right.
And live in a better place.
That's
how we got,
we got political.
Yeah.
But it is political and it,
you know,
people need motivation.
They need incentive for your actions.
People that think socialism is a good idea,
have never accomplished anything.
There's no way you've competed.
There's no way.
If you're a competitor and you understand the benefit and the value of
competition,
I'm not talking about capitalism competitive,
I'm talking about just actual competitive in anything.
Yeah.
Anything where you're trying to get a position and it's a very difficult
position.
So you want to work harder than the other people around you.
You know about merit based performance.
Like you know,
like you should,
you should achieve based on your merit based on what you have actually shown to
like how much work you've put in,
what you've accomplished.
You should benefit from that.
The idea that everybody should be paid equally and that everybody should just
have,
oh man,
we will just contribute.
And just,
uh,
I'll give a little,
you give the little dose fucks never give their share.
They're,
they're never good.
They're never the best at what they do.
They never know how to compete.
They just don't.
It's not saying that you,
that there's not some aspects of a community where we should have some socialist
ideas.
Like I believe in free education.
I believe that without a doubt,
our nation as wealthy as it is,
can afford to have better healthcare,
better education.
Yeah.
Those two things I think are gigantic factors in just having a healthy
community.
But if you want a quality of outcome,
you can suck my dick.
That's nonsense.
There's no such thing as equality of outcome because if you have real freedom,
real freedom,
you're always going to have inequality of outcome because the real freedom is a
guy like Jocko wants to get up at four 30 in the morning and work out every day,
whereas some people just want to sleep til noon.
I'd rather just lay in bed,
man,
I like to go to the beach and hang out.
I'm not,
I'm not in a hurry.
I'm not in a rush.
Good.
I hope you enjoy yourself.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But if you want the same amount of monies that motherfuckers up at four 30 in
the morning hustling,
constantly cranking out,
I've got three different things in the air.
Three different things going on.
Projects constantly,
always in the middle of something,
always pushing,
always trying to improve.
Always look at himself,
always being self critical,
always analyzing what do I have to do to get better?
And you're not,
but you want the same outcome for [inaudible].
You.
I completely
agree with that.
I feel like there's this,
the world,
oh,
especially the country is in the best place when there are more people in the
middle,
when they're,
when,
when there's these extremes.
And I feel like the Pete,
that people that were in the middle,
they've somehow been dragged further out to these extremes because yeah,
having,
um,
like going far right with some things,
right?
Um,
no,
you don't get anything.
You don't get this unless you work for it.
And you're like,
yeah,
absolutely.
100%.
And,
and,
but like some of some of the things that go along with that.
Yeah.
But then this,
everybody gets a trophy every like,
no,
everybody's in,
it doesn't get a trophy there.
There is like,
you should get a trophy if you are able to compete to the level that deserve,
that's deserving of a trophy and that's it.
Right?
Like everybody shouldn't get one.
You lost.
You shouldn't get the same thing that the guy that won got right.
You did well and you lost and you,
and there's a big competition with a big group and you did better than some of
them.
Yeah.
Maybe you get some of the,
some of the pie,
but like this whole thing of,
yeah,
everybody's equal.
I,
I disagree,
I feel like,
but I feel like there's,
there's aspects of everything that should be everywhere.
So when I say that,
what I mean is like capitalism,
like we saw,
we saw capitalism inside communism in that example.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
inside capitalism,
there should be some,
some,
some socialism,
like,
um,
let's look at the major league baseball,
right.
The Yankees,
they,
they're in the playoffs every year because they can afford ever they get
afforded by the bass player.
Right.
But like,
look at,
look at Green Bay,
Wisconsin,
small market team,
they can win a Superbowl because of the,
of the revenue share because of the socialistic revenue sharing inside the NFL.
You know,
it's,
it's a weird dynamic where there are things that,
that apply in different situations,
but like people can't compartmentalize enough so that these things can happen
and we can all make it work out.
Like I feel like,
like you said about health and education.
Um,
yeah.
Health care and education.
We have the funds for those things to be,
to be good across the board.
But why is it that the schools in this,
in this rich area always better.
They always have the better scores,
but then when you take that same,
you take the same type of um,
effort and you put that somewhere in a poor area,
their scores come up and,
and they can compete,
right?
If they have the same effort from the faculty and the staff and whatnot.
But,
um,
and same thing with like law enforcement,
law enforcement is,
is,
is better in these areas where like,
it's like there's no crime here then this is where all the rich people live and
this and that.
Right?
Yes.
But like if it,
because they also have better law enforcement,
they're a kid.
There were police patrolling that area in a different fashion.
Um,
like it's,
it's this weird thing where it's not equal,
it's not equal and it doesn't like those things should be equal.
But,
but as far as these people live in a poor area now,
and these people are,
they,
they don't,
they have a lot of money because of a family wealth,
because of work ethic.
Because of all of that.
Yeah.
Like every,
but everybody deserves to be safe.
Everybody deserves to have that at the very least.
Right.
So let's,
let's enforce the laws and in patrol and do those things in this area just as
much as we do for this area.
Right.
And put the,
put the money into that because that's a community thing now.
And we're talking about what they have.
They have nicer pools.
Well,
they pay higher taxes and they do this thing,
okay,
well if you want that,
you've now that you,
you're safe enough and your education is where it is.
Let's start reinvested in that community.
You know,
let's not,
let's not get,
get to the point where we can afford to be here.
So we go there.
No,
like we can afford to be there and um,
but let's US try reinvesting in this community to make this community more like
that one.
But if we have the protections to do that,
then I feel more comfortable reinvesting in this community.
It's,
it's a weird,
all these things are all over the place and you got to put them together.
Well,
we don't treat our country as if it's a giant community.
Right?
If it was a giant community where everybody's equal,
we would look at all the problem spots and say,
okay,
well there these crime ridden poverty stricken communities that can't seem to
catch a break.
So the people that come out of that,
even though we're saying,
hey,
you have a,
there's an open playing field to compete.
That's not true.
Right?
Because they're coming at it with a massive different disadvantage from the jump
at the education disadvantage and environmental disadvantage in what they see
around them all the time.
They're around a lot of,
I can't catch a break dudes.
Right?
And a lot of trap,
a lot of criminals,
a lot of bullshit,
a lot of different ways you could go wrong.
A lot of things that could set you down a terrible path in life and it's around
you all the time.
And if we tried to engineer society,
so say well how do we,
how do we have less people that are disadvantaged?
How do we have less losers?
What's the best way when you got to to the problem spots,
all the problem spots we should be dumping money in.
And,
and I'm not saying that we shouldn't do anything overseas because I think a lot
of the things that we do overseas probably help and protect us over here.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of shit we don't have to do and that shit,
we could take that money and just fix cities.
Just go in and throw a ton of money and compassion.
And education and community centers and make places safe for people to learn how
to be an adult.
You know what the u s military budget is?
You're sane.
It's insane.
You have any idea?
No,
don't.
It's like 600 billion.
I think it's higher than that.
It's higher than that.
It's in the trillions.
The guys in the trillion that's like that.
That is crazy.
That,
that I kind of takes me,
let's guess you say 696 I say one point 3 trillion.
Wow.
I'm crazy though,
dude.
600 billion.
I don't even know what one point 3 trillion looks like.
Okay.
What is it
don?
Don.
Luckily both.
Technically both.
Yeah.
Well,
the thing that when you put,
when I googled it,
uh,
the last one that was reported I suppose was 2015 it was 579 five nine 7
billion.
What's Year 21?
2015 the new one that Trump just signed that was approved is for one point 3
trillion.
That's must be where I heard it.
Oh boy.
That's a lot of cash.
That's much for education,
Mr. Trump.
We don't need no stinking books.
Oh,
I think that's actually the whole bill that's 700 billion of that is for the
military.
Oh,
what's the rest of it for everything else?
Yeah.
I can imagine if someone just said 700 billion for schools,
he'd be like,
what?
Yeah,
we're fine.
We're not fucking around anymore.
Yeah.
We're ready to take over.
We're going to invest 10 years with $700 billion a year in a school system.
Man,
that's,
that sounds nice.
Right,
right.
What do you think the education budget is for the country?
If you had to guess,
what's the overall public education budget in the United States?
Primary through high school.
I never thought about it.
That's awesome.
Um,
if we go at 600 billion for the military,
I'm going to go with,
okay,
100 billion.
I'll go 100 million.
$100 million,
right.
Uh,
as of 2011 discretionary budget was 70 billion.
Whoa.
That's up from education budget.
Yeah.
2006 it was 56 billion.
So it's higher than it has been in the past.
70 billion.
And what does that cover?
Um,
there's two more fucking people that I wouldn't say that what it covers,
what it's supposed to cover and what actually covers is a different thing.
You know,
what's it supposed to cover?
I'm going to have to look deep into that.
Okay.
You just said there's too many people to so many people.
So check this out.
I,
I've,
I think the same thing,
right?
And um,
I did some slight research,
1955 I think it was guest with the population of the planet was,
oh,
we
did that the other day.
It was like 2 billion,
right?
Right.
200.
Two and a half.
Yeah,
two and a half billion.
And now we're at seven and a half billion.
When we went with him,
when I was in high school,
we went with like 85,
I think it was 5 billion.
So just since 1985 to today,
it's gone up,
doubled from almost from this fifties and now we've added another half to that
50% of that.
So many people.
But like,
like I was thinking about that and I'm like looking at it and like if we're,
if it's exponential,
right?
In 50 years we will have nearly 20 billion people on this planet.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Everybody or everywhere is going to look like Los Angeles.
Like imagine if there was still like I think in like 18 in the 18 hundreds they
were like still millions of people on the planet.
Not,
not billions.
Herod is right near the president's 2017 budget provides 69.4 billion in
discretionary funding.
Is that but that's education.
Yes.
This is for the education bill 139.7 billion in new mandatory funding for the u
s department of Education.
The budget supports implementation of every student succeeds act,
which embraces many of the reforms in the administration along has long
supported to improve outcomes for all students.
That also makes crucial investments that build the administration's work to
advance educational equity and excellence support teachers and school leaders
promote college affordability and completion.
These include,
I think college should be free.
I think we could figure out how to make college free.
I'm with Bernie Sanders on that.
It's a rare thing.
I just don't think you should be in fucking debt up to your ass hall by the time
you get out of school.
I think it's crazy.
It's a fucked up way to start your life and people are like,
well you want to make a lump district separates the people that really want it
and the people that know bull shit.
You get stuck in debt and you can't even get out of that debt.
It's not even regular debt.
It's blood debt.
Some weird debt but doesn't,
doesn't have a more educated society.
Help everybody.
Everybody in the long run,
sure
we'll make more money.
Everybody would make more money like I don't get that users,
but you would have to like make sure that whoever the fuck is teaching these
kids,
like you'd have to be real stringent with what you're letting get pushed through
if you're going to throw that much money on it.
There's a lot of shit bag and teachers out there.
We'd have to clean that up.
You know,
a lot of people,
there's a lot of shitbag teachers out there and now they want to give him gun.
That's the dumbest shit of all time.
I'm like,
I was the dumbest shit.
That is the dumbest shit of all time.
You can't expect teachers to become soldiers.
That's crazy.
That's not what they do.
They're not,
they're not warriors.
They shouldn't be out there.
Have a firefights with pilled up,
you know,
formal,
former high school students.
Yeah,
it's fucking insane.
I don't know what the solution to that is.
Honestly,
I do not know what the solution is.
You know,
the NRA thinks it's having guns everywhere.
The anti second amendment.
People think it's getting all guns away.
Um,
but you're not going to get all the guns away.
The thing about life,
people say guns don't kill people.
People kill people.
I'm like,
no.
People with guns kill people.
They definitely do hear exactly how much the government would have to spend to
make public college tuition free.
How much do you think it is?
Okay,
let me guess.
1 trillion a year.
Wait way,
way less.
Way less.
Yeah.
I would say orange,
this article.
Okay.
What does it say about it?
But what is,
what is the website?
The Atlantic Atlantic.
Okay.
That's a left leaning website,
but it cannot ridiculous.
Yeah.
Dated this,
the article says 62 point $6 billion a mere 62 but there's updates on the bottom
of the article that said,
that's some readers say that's an addition to what they already spend.
So that makes it maybe double,
well,
you know,
one way they make it really fucking cheap,
have it available for free online.
Everybody should be able to get an education online.
That's what I really firmly believe that I think they should have courses that
you could just sign up and take them like a regular college course.
You don't have to be in a physical location anymore.
That's so retro.
That's so unnecessary.
Get in your car and get the traffic and go to UCLA.
The only thing good about that,
as you're in the room with someone like a Jordan Peterson or some really good
professor that's really inspirational and you're in there with him,
they talked to you and you're like,
oh,
okay.
And you get to like be in their presence and see like,
oh,
this guy was probably like my age one day and he figured all this shit down and
like,
oh,
maybe some extra juice to that
to have a bookmark saved.
I think it was Harvard.
I,
it was a long list of us recorded lectures that were from any class.
I think there's probably was a limit to what they were doing.
It's definitely not accessible anymore,
especially for the public.
But it was fully accessible.
Anybody that wanted,
that's why I had it saved.
Hmm.
Oh no Joe.
I mean when I think about that,
like I said earlier,
like all these formulas fit into different things.
You say that and it's like you can be at home while you're looking in her mind,
his screen and I'm learning versus being in the same room.
And it's like,
yeah,
but like you could also go to a strip club and watch strippers dance or he can
be at home watching them porn and when you're at home watching him,
you're going to pull it out.
Rip One.
Hmm.
You know?
Right.
So you're saying,
let's say,
and he's like,
if you're at home,
you're just going to beat off.
That's,
that's a real problem.
You know?
Uh,
Louis C K was saying once that,
uh,
he has a computer that he writes on.
It's not connected to the Internet because you just can't get distracted,
forced himself to,
I think that's what I'm saying.
The problem is the distraction with having,
having access to everything right there.
That's true.
Um,
but when you open the window with the teacher,
that's,
that's the process part.
It's discipline,
it's discipline.
And that,
that goes back to what I believe.
That ties back into what I was saying before about all this entertainment out
there.
Everybody,
everybody's,
it is always like scratching at you.
Like,
hey day,
pay attention to me.
Give me something to do.
So this was some online
learning.harvard.edu.
So they allow you to study the pyramids of Giza,
ancient Egyptian art and archeology.
And it's free.
Yeah,
this is a whole course on it for,
so that's nice.
It's a bunch of them.
How many courses do they have that available for free?
Tons.
I don't know that that's one that looked interesting to excellence.
They have a methadone.
Oh medicine.
I was like,
what are you giving people?
Get Methadone on what courses you could take.
Oh that's nice.
No problem.
Then you'll get credentialed.
So if somebody wants you to have a job for it,
you can't show them like I took this frequency and passed it.
But that seems to be less and less of a factor in in the future.
I think having a degree is going to mean less than it means now.
I think so I feel like um,
with the Internet,
yeah you can't,
if you have the right guidance,
you got the syllabus from,
from a,
from a college course and you have the Internet without getting the paper that
says you,
you done it.
You can literally learn which you would learn in a classroom.
It's like a test for the job.
You do like say if you're a car stereo installation person,
you should have a real deep knowledge of the electrical systems in an automobile
and what electronics sync up with that and how it works well and what makes them
work.
And how does a radar detector work?
How does this CD player work?
How does you,
should we have to take a test based on whatever the job it is you're interested
in?
You know,
and if you want to be a doctor,
obviously we're talking about different ball of wax,
you know,
then you should have a full understanding of humans.
You're cutting people open and drain their shins and shit.
He should,
he should,
he should have a real deep understanding of the human body.
But like how does it do you any good?
If you want to be a mechanic or if you want to be,
you know,
whatever the fuck you do for a living,
there should be a way where you could,
like if you're an advertising executive,
you should take a test to find out how much you know about the advertising
business and there's a lot of shit that you don't need to know that you went
school for their degree.
Yeah,
there's,
there's some weird things that go along with that though.
It's like,
um,
you have all these things that you have to,
to take these courses to graduate.
Just getting general education.
Yeah.
You have to get a general education,
which is a good thing,
right?
You want people to understand what understand the world,
But,
um,
there are things that are more important and can take that back to high school.
And we could talk about like everybody knows the Pythagorean theorem in high
school,
but he can't fit you.
You can do your taxes and you,
you start working,
most people start working at like 16.
When you start working at Mcdonald's or a gap or something at 1617,
you're still paying taxes at the end of the year.
Right.
So having,
having had doing that in February and March in school,
in your math classes,
how is that not something that happens?
You know?
Um,
it's just,
it's one of these weird situations where the education is important,
right?
But let's learn the things that actually apply to life.
I feel like you should get out of high school
with a basic understanding of most things.
Yes.
Right?
Like general education.
High school makes sense.
Right?
But I feel like once you get into college,
whatever the fuck you're trying to pursue,
well it should be very specified,
very specific to whatever the fuck you're,
you're,
you know,
your business is,
you don't need to take gender studies class,
but also you probably don't necessarily need all the textbook knowledge because
there is,
um,
you know,
there especially there's certain jobs that actual experience matters more than
the textbook knowledge.
You,
you,
I don't,
I couldn't tell you exactly which ones.
Well,
how about with Jamie does is a problem with Jackson job.
He went to school to be an audio engineer,
but all that shit that you use back then,
but that shit's all useless.
Yeah.
How much of is useless?
I mean the hardest test I think I took was after we were all done was a for a
pro tool.
It's basically for a computer program to get certified that you know,
this program very well.
Like what's almost most,
you were explaining that program is like version six of the program.
It was back then.
I think they're updating it maybe once every two years.
It's been updated like four times this year probably.
And they're on level like 11 now.
So it's like completely useless that I know all of that.
They've updated all,
all of the limits are completely like unlimited things now.
So it doesn't even matter that you know all that.
So someone getting out of school with just the education that you got in school
literally can't do it today.
You'd have to go back and do it again.
Sort of.
They offer that at the school.
Like you can go back and um,
uh,
refresher,
right?
Yeah.
For free.
That's part of the benefit of going to this school I would say,
but like to have the time and the ability to go back to Florida and stay there
for a month.
So I could go take that class,
like can't take a month off of this to do it and like,
who's going to pay for my apartment down there and here?
It's a really tough situation.
You put yourself in this.
That's a lot with a lot of,
uh,
anything that has to do with technology,
right?
Where it's constantly moving,
changing and,
and thing about technology.
It's like if there's some savant in that,
you know,
Pete there,
these kids and these people that pick up on technology and they understand it so
well and they have no formal education with no real format education.
Right.
The technology's one of those things that I especially,
I feel like it's the most apparent thing where you don't have to go to school,
you have to have the experience and you have to be engrossed in whatever the
subject is.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But then again,
it comes back to what we're talking about with discipline.
Like how much time do you want to spend to work on things and look that's
applicable to finding like you,
you knew so many people in the gym that just did not put the time into drilling
techniques and learning them and really getting a fully comprehensive
understanding of why you're supposed to do something a certain way.
And they just kind of like listened a little bit,
worked out kind of hard and maybe they had a little bit of athletic talent and
then they would come back in.
But the guys who would stay and drill and think and learn and take notes,
those guys always moved past.
Yeah.
They always moved further.
And it also the guys that we're willing
to do what was uncomfortable going to do,
the things that they're not good at.
Like,
um,
I didn't,
I didn't like it.
I,
like I said,
I don't like getting hit.
I didn't like getting hit.
I mean,
I accept that as a part of the job,
but I didn't like it when I first started training.
I probably feel like my first 10,
15 fights,
I was like showing up late to practice because boxing was first.
I didn't want a spa.
I didn't want to get hit like I,
and so I was like,
well,
I don't like getting hit.
I got to avoid getting hit,
but I gotta be,
I gotta have studying things coming in and meet us to learn how to avoid that.
Wow.
So I would,
I would,
I started showing up on time.
I started doing more boxing and they started doing more boxing.
I was like,
Oh,
this is fun.
This is,
I like this.
I'm enjoying this.
Same thing with wrestling.
I know how to sprawl.
I knew how to shoot a double,
a basic double,
you know,
the,
the 1990s double.
But,
um,
then I started training with Tyron,
then I started treating with Steve Brown and Dan [inaudible] and Jordan lean and
you know,
these,
these dd one wrestlers and starting to learn all the other aspects of wrestling.
There was something I did in the fight with stout.
Where is that ankle breaker?
I tried to,
it's not,
it doesn't actually breaking my ankle.
It's just the name of the technique where you actually watched the tape and you,
you call it like a standing,
he'll hook right where I have his ankle,
single leg.
And I tried to trip him and crank his leg down.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
I would've never done that if I hadn't been wrestling with these kids and
learning these things.
And there's so much,
so much about it and it just became a whole lot of fun now.
Like I used to hate wrestling.
I used to not want to do it at all now.
Like it's all kind of like all I want to do you see that with
everything.
You see that with Jujitsu guys getting into striking,
she would is getting into the ground game wrestlers getting in the striking.
Yeah.
They just don't want to do it.
They just don't and they also particularly don't want to get involved in
something they're not really good at.
Like if you're a monster at one thing,
like if you're a monster on the ground,
you don't want to be a white belt,
a kid kickboxing.
Yeah.
Your legs chewed up and get your nose bloodied every time you spar and you,
you're covering up in the corner and be like,
I can just grab this guy and making my bitch and you can't even,
you got to just eat shots.
You know,
nobody wants that.
He saw that a lot with kickboxers in particular that would go into Jujitsu class
and just did not like how they would get humbled.
Yup.
They did not like it at all because they were literally starting from scratch.
If you don't have a grappling background and you go in there and get some black
belts and killers,
they make you feel helpless.
Yeah.
They make you feel like you,
you,
you are not safe ever.
All they have to do is grab you and it's over.
You're 100% getting choked.
That's too fucked up for some people.
They can't handle that shit.
They feel like,
and then that's the case also with like a slow plodding grappler that fights
like a dynamic striker and then you have to stand up like whoa.
And you get leg kicked it down by Edson Barboza fuck all that.
Fuck that.
I've been leg kicked
to death,
but I've taken two or three from Tiago in a practice when I first started
training in American top team and I was like,
I,
I feel good about checking kicks in.
I'm comfortable there.
But he landed a couple,
I was like,
yeah,
fuck that.
I'm like,
so I would work with Tiago a lot and I feel comfortable now checking kicks.
You might get one might get two off,
but um,
I'm not going to let,
I'm get letting you do that to me.
I don't want good whipping.
Right.
Lung.
Yeah.
He would whip it in there.
You know,
like his,
his kick was like super textbook man when he,
especially when he was in his prime,
he would throw that jab one.
He was either just throw a one,
two or a jab and then just slammed that right leg in there.
He's hopping into it.
Whoa.
Like that's how I feel like as in my boss is like the 2.0 with Tiago ovens,
you know,
he's a little faster.
Yeah.
It's in stunning.
Like especially that switch kick he throws that switch kick and you're like,
what?
Yeah,
his left leg switch Gig is probably the fastest kick I've ever seen anybody
throw from that stance.
I love to see like something lined up where you,
you time like in a regular person,
a south paws,
right.
Kick,
left kick and you,
you time his switch kick to that.
We'll also put his up against somebody else's switch kick.
He's got like a [inaudible] world championship caliber switched care.
Yeah.
Like you see like a real high level Thai boxer.
They've got that same kind of speed to it.
You watch it and you're like,
there's no comparison in the octagon.
You're not countering that.
You,
you'd be lucky to react to react in time.
You just taking it,
just taking it real quick.
But again,
we go back to that normal Grumet I'll fight as good as he was.
He got fucking mauled.
Yeah.
That's,
that's what's really crazy because he didn't get mauled in the Ferguson fight.
It was a good fight.
Ferguson was winning.
It was a good fight until Tony caught him with the doors and sunk that choke
him.
But then again,
that's a few years too.
Yeah,
definitely.
It saves them Barboza.
It might be,
they better,
everybody should be bad.
All three of those guys should be getting it better at this point.
Yeah.
Uh,
um,
but yeah,
it's,
it's dangerous.
And,
and I,
I would like to see,
I mean,
Barbosa,
he's shown improvement after that.
After every loss that he had,
he showed improvement after the Tony loss,
you know,
so this fight with Kevin Lee,
let's see,
that's right into the fucking hot of things too.
Like right out of the frying pan into the fire.
Like for both guys though.
Fuck yeah.
For those guys.
Yeah.
It's Kinda crazy.
Kinda crazy.
Kevin Lee might get beat up in that one.
Oh yeah,
man might get wheeled care act.
Yeah.
You know,
he might get Terry Adams remember that fine.
Yup.
And the crazy,
that was the first time a wheel kick ever landed in a UFC fight.
First Wheel Cafe,
right?
Yeah.
I think Seth Petra Zellie landed a wheel kick,
but he didn't knock anybody out with it.
You need someone with that kind of speed though.
Ooh.
Because the game has changed,
but then you know,
Vituro landed on rock.
A bunch of people have landed wheel kick since then.
Yeah.
But that one wheel kick was so crazy.
It was so perfect.
Atlanta ride on the jaw and just shut the lights out and he went down like a
tree.
Yeah,
he was out going down.
Yeah.
That was in Brazil.
I Dunno,
but both is a fun guy to watch.
Man.
I'm,
I'm excited to be on the desk for that one.
Yeah,
it's a good fight.
Especially those two fights.
Um,
like I,
I love watching cub and Frankie fight.
Like I still feel the same way about,
about,
I think I would love to see that later.
I'm not necessarily giving love to see,
I'm not crazy about the fight in the sense that I've seen it once and it could
go that way again.
But I am excited to see the improvements that if,
if cub is be able to make any adjustments and going into that one.
Um,
but it's not a necessary thing.
There some fights that I don't,
I don't like them just for the mathematics of the fight.
Like God,
Dustin [inaudible] I love Dustin.
He's my boy.
Right.
But I don't like it because Dustin and addy,
the fight with Dustin and Eddie,
the fight was going one way.
There was a,
was it called a no contest for disqualification.
I'm like that.
I disagree with that.
I know I'm biased,
but I feel like my argument is strong in that the ref herb came back to the
locker rooms and he explained to us that we're using the old rules.
So if by the old rules,
all three of those needs were illegal.
Right.
It doesn't matter if it was intentional.
It matters if it's illegal.
That's,
that's the way I understand it.
Right.
So that,
so that's my thing.
I feel it should be disqualified and she'd be lost.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
coming.
I think that's a real good argument.
So real good argument.
And I don't think Getty's a dirty fighter.
No,
but I do think Dustin was winning that fight up until those moments.
Yeah,
I agree.
He had heard Eddie and it stunned him on several occasions to Eddie came back
and cracked him.
There was a lot going on in that fight.
But those,
those needs where they're supposed to be a disqualification for something like
that.
Right.
And that's what the whole idea is about doing something illegal.
You do something illegal and the guy gets really hurt from it.
Yeah.
That's illegal.
You weren't supposed to do it.
It's a disqualification.
I think using the heat of the moment,
you probably didn't even know whether it was legal or not really.
It was just trying to land knees.
Yeah.
Who knows he's been rocked when you've got to put that into account as well.
He got hurt real bad in that fight.
Dustin cracked him.
Yeah.
Like a mathematically,
would you like to see the rematch?
I would like to see the rematch.
Um,
definitely.
I mean Dustin was,
was lobbying for the rematch also and then on top of that,
mathematically I feel like it doesn't make sense because Eddie just beat bkg.
Right.
So like it's like it's a good point.
This disqualification happened and this one guy got to step up the ladder.
But you've now,
if you want to step up the ladder,
you have to do exactly what he did.
Right.
Those are good point.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
Well that essentially is solidifying the position as a no contest.
Right.
Cause you're making,
you think he should have won.
I tend to agree with you and you think that he should have a better position.
Yeah.
I think a rematch would be the way to go,
but I still want to see that fight.
I'll be honest with you.
I like,
I lie as a fight fan.
Yeah.
Gates,
he boy a
cage.
He's an interesting guy.
Yeah.
Tough motherfucker.
And he throws leg kicks from like a foot away from you.
He's like right on top of you.
And he,
he swivels his hips and chops down with that leg.
He doesn't care about getting ran over with a takedown either.
Well,
he's a very good wrestler.
Yeah.
Very good.
Rest of the chooses to stand and bang,
you know,
and just breaks guys with his will done.
Michael Johnson fight.
Holy Shit.
And when you stop and think about that right after I said that,
I'm like,
God damn.
Michael Johnson's been in some fucking wars.
Yes.
He's been in some wars
with um,
with Ferguson.
I mean,
well,
he beat up Tony a bit.
Um,
but Johnson Johnson is one of those guys.
You can't count out.
Either don't,
but he,
he,
his inconsistencies with throws me off.
Yeah.
You know,
it's oftentimes very good luck in the port.
A fight when he knocked out Dustin's,
he's very good,
not fight and you know,
and then he's had his moments,
but then Elkins just take some towns,
strangles him.
It's like,
wow,
I wonder if that cut had anything to do with it,
you know?
Did he get cut in that fight?
The weight cut?
I'm sorry.
Oh,
the weight.
Just making 45 for the first time could very well be mean.
He looked real lean,
real lean.
Who knows how he felt doing it for the first time.
It's probably real hard.
Yeah.
Is he doing it again or is he going to go back up to 55?
I have not.
I have not heard.
I mean it may be out there,
but I have,
I haven't heard anything about it as far as if he's going back to 55 and not,
what's the most you ever cut?
Um,
I didn't know what I was doing the first time I made one 54 to five room and the
Sato I thought I caught 17 pounds in a day.
Whoa.
Um,
that was ridiculous.
Did you have to fight day of or day after next day after?
How'd you rehydrate ivy bags?
No,
I didn't.
I drank pedialyte.
Did it work?
I don't know.
The fight didn't last very long.
It's on,
it's on fight pass and it's,
it's hard to see.
But as a fight happens,
I throw a jab and I hit Sato was,
he's coming in,
I turned his head over and bang,
as he's coming in we clash heads and I go to my knees and I get up and I grabbed
the ropes and I'm just holding on to the ropes and the ref is like screaming at
me,
slap my ass,
telling me to get off the ropes and I'm just looking at him like,
what are you talking about?
And then he jumps on my back and he starts choking and I'm fighting and I'm,
I'm falling back and one of the ropes peels my hands off and he just thinks in,
the joke all happens in like 20 seconds.
Wow.
But like I like after learning about rehydration,
yeah.
I didn't know anything.
This is like 1999 right now.
I have to learn.
And this is the first time I fought a 55,
um,
after learning about rehydration and the brain and all that,
I'm like,
was,
was I out from that?
Like,
I,
this was when
I was a kid.
I don't care anymore about the result,
but I'm like,
was I out?
You know,
was I,
was I con semi con?
I don't remember any of that,
but I watch it on tape and I see it and I know what happens,
but I don't know.
Yeah.
So you don't know how much of a weakened state you were in because it was such a
quick fight.
You get a chance to assess how your body,
how did you feel like walking to the ring?
Do you remember?
I remember feeling good,
but I was,
uh,
I was,
20 something like 21 year old maybe fighting.
Um,
a guy who I look up to in a main event in Hawaii on a,
on a show,
on super brawl.
You know,
we're,
we're all Super Bra.
Had some great fucking fights,
man.
Like,
that's,
that's old school,
you know,
remember Egan in your way versus mayhem?
Miller.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
You can get,
some may have in the Camorra may keeps rolling out of it.
Those impossible joints.
Damn Bra fights.
It wasn't that v Tours debut against John Hess.
Yep.
Ah,
Shaq was in the audience members.
Shaq jumps out.
I don't remember that veto or lit.
John has stopped.
That's when John House was like one of the last remaining bullshit artists.
He was a safta guy.
Like street combat,
like one of those guys poking people in the eyes and shit.
And that's what he basically did.
And his UFC debut,
he poked the shit out of some guy he fought.
So he fought some short guy and poked him in the eyes.
But yeah,
this is Victoria.
This is back up a little bit.
Yeah.
But just back up a little bit because this is right before the fight starts.
Let it go here.
Oh,
it starts with a beating.
It was a weird video.
Oh,
okay.
Look at this.
Doom,
doom.
Doom.
Doom out.
Yeah.
That was super fast.
You to her.
I was training with V tour then.
Oh yeah.
Vittores 19 years old,
man.
That's when I was at Carlson Gracie's on Hawthorne is right down the street from
the comedy store.
Man,
I was so jealous to veto and that UFC Brazil when he fought Vandelay cause that
was like this kid my age.
I agree with the saint.
Were born the same year,
I guess it was like he's my,
he's already in the UFC.
I wish I was 200 pounds.
Like I remember Rod Woodson was this safety for,
for the Pittsburgh Steelers and I was like,
he's five [inaudible] nine 200 pounds cause I,
that would be,
they will only two weight classes back then.
And this is when he tried telling me,
yeah,
he fought.
He was only 200 pounds back then.
Man,
when he fought in his UFC debut and he beat the shit out of Scott for Ozo and it
was only 200 pounds and he was shout readed just shredded was fast.
Was It v against Vandelay telegram?
Telegram was his debut froze are right here.
That was the second fight of the night.
This is the first fight that I worked in Alabama in 1997.
When did he fight Vandelay and Vandelay and nice six?
No,
98 I think.
And uh,
ultimate ultimate buzz Brazil.
This is how he fought tank Abbott.
This was when [inaudible] was getting bigger,
but he was still,
it was still fast.
He was like probably like two 15 or two 20 then and then he fucked up tank
Abbott.
Um,
but then as he got older,
not older but later and see like here he's still pretty jacked.
But then when he fought Randy coture,
he got,
remember this is Joe Charles.
That might've been effects ever see that fight.
He didn't throw any punches.
They were friends and they just scrap and got him in an arm bar that was like,
they kind of had a deal.
Here's the Vandelay fight.
You got to meet the,
remember the Vandelay fight was when he had slimmed down cause after Randy had
already fucked him up.
It was after,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Well when Randy fought him,
veto was two 40 and he looked like a lion.
Yeah.
He didn't even look like a person.
See if he could find veto.
This is pride
picture of that a couple of weeks,
a couple months ago about Vitola at that point before the Randy fight.
Yeah,
because he had no known weaknesses.
Right.
That's what it said.
No known weaknesses.
He lost a sock or rob in this fight.
He hurt his hand,
broke his hand early.
And this is also,
this is Vito or after is his sister got kidnapped and murdered.
He was a different guy then.
Sakharov was so fucking tough too man.
Sakkara but just knew how to survive.
See if you could find Vituro versus Randy couture.
Cause that's the crazy one when you just look at his build.
Yeah,
he was so big man.
It's like his traps were coming up to his ears.
Oh,
here it is right here.
This is him versus Randy.
So this might be says young Vitor Belfort.
So it's probably only going to show you the good stuff.
Yes.
Yeah.
He was so thick back then,
but the thing I remember is like how big his neck was.
Like it started at the top of his head and worked its way down sideways,
a 40 degree angle.
Those are the wild west days,
man.
You know,
I mean,
how many guys did you fight where you're like,
oh shit,
this dude's definitely on the,
on the juice.
I didn't even think about juice back down,
even know what it was.
I saw it.
I thought there's a,
there's a video on youtube.
I fought this guy,
so bas Rutten was coming to Texas and I was like,
I was this huge Bosch Chute and fan.
And um,
he told my coach who's was coming,
I emailed my coach,
emailed,
he said I could be that he's supposed to fight in Dallas that night I called the
guy up in Dallas because I had fought for him before and he shorted me on some
money.
I was like,
I'm not coming up there,
man.
I'm not fighting for you.
And I went to this arena where Bosch is going to be at.
And I told the guy,
hey,
anybody,
I walked into the rules meeting,
I was like,
if anybody doesn't have an opponent,
I'll fight.
And,
um,
they gave me a guy that was like two something big Jack Dude at the big,
like a man and I was a child.
My,
my roommate was like,
Hey,
do you see your opponent?
I was like,
no.
He's like,
man,
he's like six [inaudible] two he's probably like two twenties Jack.
And I was like,
and boss was like,
Eve,
eve,
he's drinking.
He's like,
Eve,
you got there and you fight and you win.
I going to be like,
yeah,
you fight.
Then you lose.
I'm going to be like,
yeah,
fuck these people.
They don't understand what it takes to get in there.
You don't worry about it.
I little corny.
I was like,
I was so excited.
It was the coolest fucking thing in the
world.
Just haven't boss in your corner.
That's gotta be what,
a motivating factor that is.
Right.
Like I,
I,
I was as excited kid was watching all these pancreas videos.
I had pictures of my,
I had before I even knew the guy before I had any idea possibly meet him.
I have pictures of myself doing that double front kick in my head.
I still have them.
It's horrible.
But I'm like,
and then I meet the guy and he's,
he's willing to corner me and whatnot.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll fight anybody.
That's incredible.
It's like Dan Severn that seven was like,
I'll fight him right now,
although in a bottle.
That's incredible.
That's good man.
I am.
Yeah.
Sorry.
You taking me back.
Damn man.
Books.
That's one of the beautiful things about MMA is that especially with the garlic
use it,
you were there for them.
Be really at the beginning,
like the early,
early,
early days.
Man,
you were there when there was no money,
you know,
no notoriety,
no nothing.
Yeah.
Five,
five shows a year.
That type of stuff.
Like Josh Thomson posted a picture a couple of days ago of him and Hermes and
Hermes Franco.
Yeah.
I forgot about that dude.
That was,
that was,
that was a good fight.
I remember watching that and thinking like,
Josh,
has he posted something about that fight should have made him the number one guy
because like we were the guys at that point.
Yeah.
Armies and Josh and when he beat Hermes,
I was like,
I got to fight these guys.
These are the guys I want to fight.
And then I fought Hermes and then it was like,
that's it.
It's just Josh and I,
we got to do this,
you know,
um,
that highlight kick that you landed on him to his work,
one of those UFC preflight video highlight reel thing.
They would play with that.
The WHO Song?
Yeah.
The Baba Baba O'reilly would play.
And then you would land that jumping roundhouse kick to the neck.
That was a crazy highlight reel.
Kao Finished Man.
No,
that was just old school.
Good Times.
You know,
like those,
those are the guys that I remember those those days.
I remember when they had that tournament with,
um,
with Dean and Uno and Matt and,
who's the third guy?
Bj.
Mm.
And they had that tournament for the belt.
And I was like,
why am I not in this tournament?
I was angry.
I was,
I was young.
I had a little bit less fights than dean at the time.
Um,
little less experienced at that high level.
Anyway,
and I was just like,
I can fight these guys.
It could beat these guys.
I had just lost the decision at uno.
It's like,
yeah,
I know.
I know how to be on this level.
I should be in this.
I was so pissed and I'm no,
I remember those days man.
Those,
those,
it's,
it's fun thinking about them.
It's fun going back and watching the whole card because like you,
you started getting these memories of,
of being around that and preparing for those days,
being on the card and seeing those guys and um,
you know,
the fights were like in Bolger city,
Louisiana,
you know,
some small,
small town,
the small arenas where I'm close to Texas families driving over.
And then when I first went to Vegas to fight,
man,
that first fight in Vegas
was right after nine 11.
Empty.
The casinos were m I remember that does when Tito Ortiz,
fod,
Vladimir Mount your Shank Schenkel yeah,
I remember that.
That was there for that.
Yeah.
I wasn't even working for the UFC then.
No,
no,
no.
I was there as a guest.
I was there watching and that's one of them are Blotnick was there.
Yeah.
One of the ways I got the job was by become,
I became friends with Dana and Dana and I would like go to dinner and I started
asking them questions.
You know,
I'm,
I'm like,
you,
have you ever seen kinky pseudo ever seen this guy you were talking about this
guy?
He did.
She tried to do is get some of those kick k one guy to come over.
I would just be telling him all this shit about fighting.
And he was like,
you want it to commentary.
It was like,
I don't want to work,
man.
He talked me into doing it.
That's,
that's literally how it happened to come in friends with him talking to him.
Oh,
when he found some old,
he found a video of me on the Keenan Ivory Wayans show,
talking shit about,
uh,
what would happen if Steven Seagal fought in the octagon?
Yeah,
because I vaguely remember that Katelyn had been in some movie with Steven
Seagal.
I was fucking with him about the movie.
I just was just joking around and marketing it.
I remember those rumors of you and Wesley snipes getting in.
That was supposed to happen.
I should have happened.
I think he just needed money,
man.
I think he just needed tax money,
you know,
and it was at a point in my life where I was just dumb enough to do it.
I was like,
I'll do this.
And I was like,
man,
let's do it.
Got Tapped out by Andy Dick wet.
I got tickled out this,
that tickling doesn't work right?
No.
Never done that in a fight.
Like you even feel it in a fight.
You wouldn't even feel it.
Like if someone like wasted time,
like Kumu,
Kumu,
you just hit him right in the mouth.
Imagine if someone like was so ticklish that you could open up a submission,
like a ticklish ticklish tennis could open up a submission.
That's hard.
You know what you,
you might be like,
if someone's turtled up knowing you're going back,
you can hit that rib tickle.
Right.
I'm going to try that in the gym and the gym.
It might work.
I'm gonna try to rip decal so many in the gym when I get them back next time.
Is Anybody,
here's a question.
Does anybody ever knocked the guy out where someone's on your back and you hit
on with one of these and knock them out?
I have never seen that.
I've never seen it either,
but I've seen people keep trying it.
They keep trying it.
Right.
I don't think anybody's ever knocked anybody out with that.
Like can you practice that?
Like could you get a guide to do ride your back with the pads on and he would
hold up pads and you had fucking,
it sounds dumb as shit.
Sounds dumb as shit.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
I would,
I wouldn't do that.
I should know.
What does work that you can't do headbutting.
Yeah.
Like if a guy's on your back and if you've got risk control and you smash your
head into his head,
that is a legitimate technique.
You're smashing the back of your head and knew his nose.
That's legit.
Yeah,
that's legit.
But it's a headbutts headbutts illegal,
but it opens up a rear naked.
Yeah.
But it's a good,
it's not the best defense.
The best defense is proper Jujitsu defense.
But there's something to headbutting someone who's got your back that it's
another thing they have to think about.
Yeah.
But if you lot headbutts,
then you would allow the ultimate move from the runic a choke position,
which is him elbow and you in the back of the head.
That's the ultimate move.
Yeah.
That changes the whole position.
But also headbutts changed the guard position to remember Mark Coleman when he
fought Maury Smith and those old days Coleman would get on top of guys and just
smash his fucking head right into your nose.
It was a,
there was an event on it from Australia from way back in the day from I think
the late nineties where this guy,
one one and one of one of his fights in the tournament and maybe a couple of
fights,
um,
from inside the guide head buddy.
Whoa.
And then I remember that,
I remember the guy who put his chin in the guy's eye socket marker.
That was Kurt.
Kurt did that.
Okay.
Dan mobish fought Dan Boba fish,
got on top of them,
got the back of his head,
stuffed his chin and his eye socket and lifted up the back of his head,
crushed his chin into his eyeball Ui.
That's gross.
That's as gross as it gets.
It's horrible.
Yeah man.
You see,
I seen a lot of,
I've seen a lot of those,
you know,
from the old school,
you see there was these things that would happen that would never happen today.
You know,
and,
and it's,
it's fun to watch some of that old stuff and grew this guy.
He's just,
he's just running,
running in.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Is that going to work?
That's only tech tar.
And it looks like it.
And the right for a second.
I thought it was old leg right?
And he had no,
he would never do something that that's,
that's,
that's a question I like to ask young.
Like,
you know,
like when they ask them rappers,
what do you think?
Run DMC,
right?
That's a question.
That's a name that I'll drop one in young fighters like,
oh,
like duck taller over Jerry Boone Landry or some jewelry.
Polander know Jerry bull and it became a cop.
Yeah.
Wilson Kobe became a cop too.
He's like Swat Cop.
No Shit.
Yeah.
He's a talented guy and he's like one of the baddest Swat cops on the force
right here.
Yeah.
I would imagine he was a talented guy.
He was the guy that I was Kinda surprised,
didn't go further.
Wilson was one of those guys who I believe
couldn't put it together inside the octagon as well as he could in the gym and
also had a little bit,
he could have put more effort into preparing.
Well that's oftentimes the case.
The difference between someone who just does fantastic and someone who just
doesn't quite just someone who falls off short.
Yeah.
I think it also comes from like,
you know,
the,
the way you come up in the sport.
Um,
some of these guys,
they come up and they're the best guy in their,
in their area for a long time.
And,
um,
you kind of get this attitude or this,
you started developing this persona of like,
I don't have to do all that work because like I,
I'm not even doing that much and I'm
still smashing everybody in here.
Well that's where it's crazy about the garlic.
John Jones.
He actually can do that.
Yeah,
right.
He's one of the rare guys that actually can do that.
Man.
I like,
I wonder how much money he's left on the table with,
with all these problems,
especially with the tension that Khan has brought to the sport and a guy like
Jon Jones.
Yeah.
You know,
I know it's good as he is good as he is and I feel like for the longest time
too,
he was trying to push this goody two shoes image and everybody was like,
well that's not you.
This is fake.
And then all of his problems sort of forced him to just be himself and then
people were like,
we like you worn out.
And then he winds up testing positive for something else,
which I believe him,
it was accidental.
I believe that it was accidental in this,
in this case,
because it doesn't make any sense any other way.
Because if you look at how he tested positive in what he tested positive for and
how recently tested negative before that and how recently afterwards he tested
negative,
you're talking about something that was a such a minuscule trace amount,
there's no way you can consider taking something like that and having it to have
some sort of positive effect,
performance enhancing effect.
Now was that the substance?
Is it oral?
Is it can be taken away or it can be taken orally.
So I've heard,
I've heard,
and I don't know how true this is,
I would expect it to be somewhat true,
but I've heard like in boxing,
you know,
you,
um,
main vendors,
they've had these,
these issues where they would only,
they would provide their own food because they don't trust the staff for
somebody,
you know,
spiking their food with something.
So they test.
So I don't,
um,
I mean that sounds far fetched,
but it also sounds to some degree reasonable.
Um,
his position was weakened by his testimony in the California State Athletic
Commission hearing because,
um,
first of all,
he said that Malki had forged his signature on one of the documents on one of
the things that he was supposed to have gone over.
Like what you can and can't,
I don't know.
I think it was a,
you saw the paperwork or maybe it was California state athletic,
mentioned commissioned paperwork.
Um,
he apparently admitted that his manager forge a signature and they asked him,
have you ever considered getting a new manager?
And he joked around,
but yeah,
he has.
He said,
no,
I'm just kidding.
Um,
but that's not good.
And then there was a bunch of stuff in like what he provided as a possible
source of that stuff.
You know,
like he didn't,
he didn't have in these a lot of the things that he provided as a source of
stuff in his list of stuff that he had taken.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a lot going on there,
man.
But the real problem is like John at one point and Thomas being represented by
Nike.
I mean he was representing Nike.
He was,
he had a huge Nike contract.
Yeah.
And that's,
and that's huge.
I mean damn that was giant cause that was pre Reebok too.
That was the pre pre Reebok days where he would have got all the juice.
He would've got it all.
And you know what can the have,
should have a shit goes on forever and on top of the top of that of um,
the Coulda woulda Shoulda of that being pre Reebok and it being Nike with
everything that comes to the sport sends.
Then imagine if John like he could like,
he could have done it,
gone to Jordan route in some sense.
You know why he's got like a whole line of John Jones Shawnae type shit.
That's nice.
Sure.
Nine,
you know,
it could be the heavyweight champion right now.
Who knows?
I mean who knows.
We could absolutely.
Absolutely.
He could be in a super fight with Steve Bay.
Yeah,
absolutely.
100% absolutely.
That'd be a huge fucking fight,
man.
Frank MMA,
John Coming up to heavyweight.
I mean,
it's a huge fight with DC coming up to heavyweight.
Yes.
You know,
and the only guy,
the only guy to have a best in his job and not just best to me,
k owed him.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean he hit him with that left high kick.
That's that DC said,
you're not going to hit me with that left kick.
Yeah.
Literally said that because he was saying he exposes some tendencies like,
oh,
you mean the left care,
you're not going to hit me with that left hot kick and then boom,
he lands a left high kick.
Is that like the titanic a little bit like,
yeah.
It only saying because they said it wouldn't.
Yeah,
maybe.
Well,
but that's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
We are a couple,
a couple of weeks ago I saw you at the comedy store and you ask me about your
boy Brendan.
Yeah.
And like you,
you had asked me about you,
you were to explain,
explain the whole thing to people that don't know the story.
Brendan said something where he was talking about UFC tonight,
right.
It's,
you'll see tonight,
well,
he's talking about the pat of the Fox Paddle Fox panel and he said something
about,
I get it,
Fox,
you're not racist.
Like saying that you have a bunch of black people on it.
Yeah.
Fell off,
fell broadcasts and because they're not racist,
um,
myself tiring.
And,
and Karen Bryant with the three that were on the desk that day,
but also a lot of times we're shod a lot of times DC.
Um,
and so it was like,
I bet are you checking off boxes because the,
are these the best brains in the best speakers for this,
for the job.
And it was like,
and you know,
I,
some people see the point that he was trying to make the point that he claims
that he was trying to make.
Um,
but the thing is,
when you,
when you start,
when you start in on this race thing,
you're saying effectively that these,
there's a person or a group of these people are only there because of the color
of their skin.
Right.
Um,
you could,
you could say all of that without,
without the whole,
I get it.
You're not racist,
you're are you checking off boxes or whatever.
Right.
Because if that doesn't matter to the question,
that was the point that you're trying to make them.
Why bring it up,
Brian?
You know,
that's,
I feel like I know Brendan very well.
I love him.
He's one of my best friends.
He's definitely not a racist,
but he definitely talks too much.
Yeah.
And I don't mean that in a bad way.
Like he talks
too much.
I mean,
like he says his too many podcasts and too many things and you say things and
I'm,
I'm 100% guilty of this.
He say things and you're like,
why don't even say that?
And then all of a sudden you're defending it and then you're,
you're caught up in,
you know,
just like a wave of just trying to sort out what you're saying without someone
being there to say,
well,
look,
here's thing.
Tyron Woodley UFC welterweight world champion,
uh,
Eve Edwards,
arguably the best one 55 are in the world at one point in time.
Massive veteran in sport.
Um,
you can go down the list.
Rashad Evans,
former light heavyweight champion.
I mean,
you're talking about top flight champions,
former champions,
elite mixed martial artists,
but you also have Bisbing y'all said Paul Felder,
you also have Kenny.
Yeah,
Kenny Florian.
You know,
you have just,
they're just elite top of the food chain fighters and analysts.
I think it was a bad path to go down.
I don't think it made sense.
I just,
I think he thought it made sense in his head when he was saying it.
I think maybe he was trying to be controversial.
Maybe just,
I don't know.
You know,
it didn't make sense to me.
Yeah.
It didn't make sense to me though.
But like my,
my thing about it wasn't okay,
you're being racist.
Right?
Um,
like it's,
it's a thing when you bring race into the,
to the situation too.
Right.
But my thing wasn't,
you're racist because you say this.
My thing was you're saying that I'm in this position because I'm not good
enough.
Right.
You're saying that I'm only here because of affirmative action or whatever you
want to call it,
you know,
um,
there's not a quality to my work and that's where I'm like,
yeah,
fuck that.
That's,
that's not the case.
I know.
I know that I'm good at,
I know that I'm good at the sport,
I understand the sport and I'm good at explaining what I see.
Brian,
who would,
you know,
the other thing is like who would replace them?
Are we,
is there a white people that are missing out?
Yeah.
On the GIG.
Like who's,
who's went to an audition?
Yeah.
Who's not getting the job though as they're like someone who's like,
wow,
this guy really speaks really well,
but they're holding them down because he's white.
Has that even happened?
Yeah.
Some people they would probably be like that to happen,
but I don't think that's actually happened.
Yeah.
I,
I agree completely,
but,
so we kind of,
we kind of went through that.
You know,
I,
um,
he sent me a message,
he apologized about that and I was like,
cool.
Like my thing was not about the race thing.
My thing was,
you said these things and you either saying somebody or a group of people up
there aren't qualified for the job.
You're insinuating that a group of people that you belong to.
Right.
We're not qualified to do to the jail.
So that,
that,
that's where I was coming from with it.
Yeah.
And then I thought it was squash,
but then he said some other stuff after that.
And that's why I'm like,
man,
what did he say afterwards?
Um,
he was,
I think,
I forget the guy's name.
Luke.
Luke,
sorry.
I remember Luke Thomas,
right?
He was on this guy,
Luke Thomas show and easy saying stuff east civically talking about me now.
It's like,
yeah,
I to them,
we're all friends I talked to eat and he's like,
well,
see eaves,
there's something eve season himself.
And I'm just like,
man,
you're not,
you're not.
Yeah,
Nike's Isa.
I feel like that's something you've seasoned himself.
He was aggressive and this,
that,
you know,
he said,
he said he was,
um,
he was emotional and this and that.
And I'm like,
like there's an,
I never said to you,
I was emotional.
Um,
none of these things.
So like you're like,
this bus is coming,
you're waiting to throw me in front of it or some shit like that.
And I'm like,
yeah,
no that's not cool man.
Like we're not friends.
We know each other.
They extent of our friendship is like a UFC.
Last summer I saw Brendan across the aisle and some guy rolled up on him and his
talking to him for like 10 minutes and I'm looking back and I could see
Brendan's like [inaudible] die cause I'm like,
let me,
let me go try and help him out.
So I go over there and I started talking to Brendan and then to do it just hangs
out.
I talked to Brandon for about five,
10 minutes and then the dude just hanging out behind us and I'm just like,
that's all I got man.
I'm going back to my seat.
When the guy jumped in,
the guy jumps right back in.
That's the extent of it.
I've seen him at different places beyond that.
You know,
Brian and I are cool.
So I've seen him sometimes when I seen Brian,
but like we're not boys.
We don't know each other like that.
So,
and like she,
and you're not a psychologist,
you're not a psychiatrist,
so you're not qualified to be speaking on my mental state.
No.
That he said that.
I feel like now that I'm remembering it,
you might've brought that up at the comedy store the other night.
It didn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any I,
I'm Brendan's friend and I can't defend them on that cause it doesn't make any
sense.
It just didn't,
it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
But sometimes he says,
shit,
that doesn't make sense.
And maybe if you were in the room with them,
he wouldn't have said it.
Or maybe he would have said it better.
Or maybe he would have,
you know,
set.
Are these really the best minds?
But here's the argument.
If they're not,
who are like,
you really,
if you say,
are these really the best minds,
you really should provide better alternatives.
So who are the better alternatives?
Who is a better alternative?
I mean there's,
there's a bunch of really good guys online.
Brendan Dorman does some really good stuff.
Lawrence Kenshin does some really good stuff about analyzing stuff.
I don't know how good they are on camera.
There's a bunch of people like,
um,
you know that the do good Robin black does some real good breakdowns and stuff
like that.
I mean maybe there's an argument that he would do a great job,
but something like that for sure.
But you got to provide,
if it's not like there's like some overwhelming absence of the best guys where
they're saying,
hey,
why are you going with these black guys instead of going with the best guys?
Why don't you have blah blah blah,
there's no blah blah,
blah.
Like there's no guy out there.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like who would that guy be?
Okay.
I have no idea.
But there's also a formula.
I mean like you and Jimmy Smith kind of other exception to the formula and the
formula is to have,
you know,
the,
the color guy in the play by play guy in the play by play guy.
He's usually the one with the actual experience.
Right?
You've been doing it so long,
you're as close to having the experiences.
Anybody can write
without having it.
Mel and Jimmy's right there next to you in that was more experienced than me
cause he's fought MMA,
right?
Yeah.
He had some,
he's had a couple of fights.
Yeah,
right.
Not at that level but he understands Robin black has had like two or three
fights also,
you know.
Um,
so that's the formula though.
You know I'm,
Karen is on the other side of that.
Karen just her role is similar to Goldie's.
You know,
she is the person that that asks the questions that has an idea but doesn't have
the experience right now and she represents,
she represents the fan for the most part.
She does it in a non robotic way.
Right.
Very important to like for the person watching.
If you've got some guy who's like a radio DJ coming out to those people,
they know how to say the right words and they can do it and seem professional
but you don't,
it's your not smooth.
Whereas Karen knows how to be fun and she can be loose and she's non robotic
while she be knowledge professional.
She has a knowledge of the sport.
To some degree and a cushion for it.
Exactly.
The Passion is what makes it makes it even more out of her.
You know?
I was watching NFL the other day and I was watching.
It was,
it was with,
you were whatever it was where I was like,
does that girl really the best person to be interviewing these fucking giants?
Wasn't you?
I was like,
is that girl?
But she's hot.
She's hot as fuck.
I was like,
does she really know about football?
Or she is just a gig because she wants to be famous.
You know what I mean?
Like there's a lot of those.
Whereas you would say,
okay,
there's gotta be someone out there that's better,
who really understands the game,
who could get in there and ask questions to this dude and find out why,
why they chose that play,
what went wrong?
What was he thinking when this happened?
Like someone who really is a fan of it.
That's what I want to see with fighting,
you know?
I mean,
that to me,
fighting is so much more personal,
so much more intense.
When I see someone that's interviewing someone,
I want to see someone who really fucking cares because I know there's a lot of
people who do care and I care.
Like if I'm interviewing someone after a fight,
I'm trying my best to figure out like what was happening in their head.
There's some critical moments I want to know was this there?
Was this a plan?
Did you see this in advance?
Does something you saw in training when you're watching tapes?
I've questioned it's like fan questions.
So I do my best to relay those.
That's what I do my best.
If I feel like someone phoning it in or this isn't a job they're interested in
or they really just want to be.
And you know,
some other sport,
they really wanted to be a fucking baseball commentator,
but there was no gig.
Yeah,
they're just fucking half ass in it,
you know?
It's just,
it's,
it's weak,
it's terrible.
I one thing I love,
the one thing I always tried to do,
I always wanted to make,
I tried to make you laugh every post fight,
interview,
any time.
Like it was like I won.
Have knock out.
Okay,
I'm going to talk to Jill.
Let's,
let's see what he gives me.
See if he gives me something,
I could try to make it.
Sometimes I came with something set up,
but um,
there's one time I forget who it was.
I think it was a Jeremy Stephens and um,
you had asked me to take you through the replay and I was literally watching it
and um,
you had asked me question and I wasn't even paying attention to you,
but so it worked out perfectly.
You would like to,
I was like jobs.
I was watching that
and I was going to ask you to ask the question again and it hit me.
I was like,
and I was just thinking,
damn,
I'm smooth
and I got that reaction out of you.
So that was fun.
That would be the actual reaction.
He said that I also like helping the Gar celebrate,
you know,
like there's moments like when someone does something where someone almost has
to tell you like how amazing that was.
Like,
you know,
it was amazing,
but I want to,
I wanted to let you feel it even more.
I want you to,
you know,
like,
like when rose,
Nama Eunice beat you,
Ana like dad to me it's like one of my favorite all time post fight interviews
cause she's like,
y'all just be a good person.
It's about don't mean shit.
Damn rose is out there.
You know,
she's so unusual.
And to have her walk through it like this impossible underdog coming in and even
if she wanted,
but he thought she went by submission.
I didn't think she'd just stepped in and cracker with a left hook and then
dropper.
Like what?
That was crazy.
Like watching that fight was crazy.
Here's a good one for you on it.
On an another big fight.
I feel like there is a moment right in a fight,
especially when you get a finish sometimes is a moment that comes just before
the finish that you recognize this opportunities there and you jump on it.
Um,
and then there are times when like before the moment happens,
it's like before the shot comes just like this guy's about to fill this right
hand and I know I'm going to slip it and drop and drop my right on top of it.
Right.
Um,
but then there are times when you hit a guy and it's like,
oh this is my chance.
Right.
Jump on him and you know,
the end is near and all that rush when the referee steps that,
that's the moment.
That's the biggest moment when the referee stops the fight,
that's when you come.
You know what I mean?
So like if you can figure out how to ask that question because getting good,
getting someone to explain that moment is,
is if they can translate that.
That's so sweet.
Cause like I like I can think of what my lab,
one of my last vice when it was Steven's like when I hit him I didn't,
I knew what I was doing and I knew I was going to land the punch.
Then as he went down,
it was like,
Oh shit,
here's that moment when you jump on it,
you know,
being able to beat,
that's,
that's what the best thing to get out of guys.
And you,
you asked that question.
Well,
but also if you,
if,
if they can see it coming,
man,
seeing that coming,
that's the thing.
That's when he's like,
this chick is hot and I know I'm going to get it.
It's that moment when it's like,
oh,
this is actually happening.
What do you miss the most about fighting?
Like what don't I miss?
It's,
I love that challenge man.
Like that's why I still like training and whatnot,
but,
but the actual fight itself,
it's because everything's on the line.
They already thought about doing grappling competitions or anything where it's
no striking.
I,
I have not.
I've been,
I thought it once or twice,
but not been committed to doing it.
Um,
I'm starting to train more now again.
I had some,
some things happening in life that were changing for me.
I just moved out here and I didn't have the,
um,
the team,
the foundation behind me.
I didn't have the,
the group that I was with all the time anymore.
I had to find a,
find a new group,
started building new group and now that we have this group,
um,
I feel more comfortable.
I'm back in the gym more,
I'm able to do more like that and like I'm still in good shape and yeah,
I feel like maybe I want to compete again,
but just for the fun of it,
you know,
not for it not to try and be a world champion.
Anything as uh,
in MMA or compete in Jujitsu.
I still love him and May,
it doesn't make sense.
So,
you know,
um,
there are definitely some fights that I wish could have happened or that I would
have had.
Like what,
what far do you feel like you missed out on fighting?
Call me at one point.
You know when go mia was gummy.
Yeah.
Like throw those fucking fast pitch baseball punches,
man.
Like the,
the,
the pride tournament.
I would have loved to fight everybody in that tournament.
And you know,
every individual I find hats and that was fun.
He smelled like ass.
But that was fun.
It was horrible.
Do you think he did it on purpose?
One of those?
He does that.
Every fight just doesn't smell.
It doesn't wash her.
Some days is bad.
Um,
shoot.
soccer,
I like fights like that,
you know?
Um,
but like now there's,
there's still some guys,
uh,
I have a lot of respect for.
I,
I talked to Joel Lozan about it.
I was like,
man,
I'd love to fight a guy like Joe on,
you know.
Um,
but that was right after like the first year of being retired.
How many years you've been retired now?
Five.
Three or f.
Since 2000.
There's almost four.
Almost four.
November before feel it seems like longer for some strange reason because you
just missed me till I do.
You just miss it,
you know?
I do.
You just miss seeing that right leg,
left leg kick.
But um,
no,
it's,
it's one of those things where you,
you love it so much.
There are times when I'm watching fights,
man,
and there's some guys that are like just outside the top 15.
I couldn't tell you any names right now,
but let me like,
like,
uh,
like Jake Matthews when he was a 55.
Like,
I feel like this kid is good and he's awesome.
He's all set.
They're much bigger than they were back in my day.
But it's still,
I'm like,
man,
sometimes I watch fights and I'm like,
you mother fuckers is so lucky.
I'm not 25 just because of the fees,
you know,
now know.
But isn't that the thing?
Right.
The older fighters have way more knowledge and understanding of what to do,
but their body doesn't respond that way anymore.
And that's sort of the balance of it all is that the young fighters have all the
piss and vinegar and fast twitch muscle fibers and they don't know that much.
I,
for me,
I feel,
cause I still move around and still sparse this morning.
We're like Joe and Mickey and those guys and I,
I can,
I can do a lot of the things that I've always been able to do.
Uh,
it has to do with,
for the most part,
for me,
the recovery.
Like the next day,
if I go hard today,
I can't go hard tomorrow.
I can't,
I can't go hard four days a week anymore.
You know,
I could go hide once or twice a week and as I get in better shape,
like the twice will be more consistent.
But,
um,
the recovery I can still move very close to just as fast as I've always been.
Like I think that will go away at some point,
but I still have it.
Um,
and I can't take it like I used to.
Yeah.
You know that that's a difference.
Um,
I don't like in the gym I can still,
like I still walk through some things,
but I don't know about in competition when,
when it's all in line.
Cause again,
I think your brain kind of,
you're in a different mindset,
you know,
think about that when you're sparring right now because you really don't have a
need to write.
I um,
I still love sparring.
I don't,
I don't do it nearly as much as I used to.
Uh,
I do think about that.
So fun though.
It's so much fun.
You know,
and I'm like,
you only got one,
right?
Yeah.
You got one.
I don't,
I don't want to be,
want to live the last 20 of that one drooling,
shitting your pants.
Word Mark.
I don't want that.
So I try to exercise my brain as much as I can.
But what do you do?
You know,
reading,
I do a lot of,
a lot of the cognitive,
not co,
but brain cognitive games like,
uh,
you know,
a lot of things with numbers and crosswords and,
and,
and I just,
that's a hard thing for me to not do something because if I'm not,
if I'm awake and I'm not occupied,
my thoughts are just going.
So that's something else I've been doing.
I've been,
I've started to write things down.
I've been doing like some stunt work acting,
right.
So I've been,
lately I've been watching old shows and just watching it for the acting and,
and I'll,
I'll find a script and I'll stand in front of a mirror by myself and do some,
do some things and tried to pay some things out.
Like,
I'm just like,
I'm just,
I was just going through all of it.
I,
uh,
I did,
I did a small move.
They're doing a movie about nick knew well.
Right.
And,
um,
I f I,
so I fight the cat.
The guy that's played nick knew well and one scene early in his career was the
fighter has one our,
cause the guy in the movie,
everyone armor as well.
No,
but he,
they greenscreen it.
Oh,
I'm so,
so he's,
he's the whole time he has his green sleeve over his arm and he has it out here
and he's moving it.
And we have,
we choreograph the fight and we have to kind of address a account for all of
that in the choreography with the green screen and all that are all low.
But I got a couple of lines.
I did some lines in the first time I did lines with Kevin Pollak.
So that was cool for her.
You know,
that's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
and then I did an episode of ballers for the next season,
so that was cool.
Did you work with the Rock?
No,
I worked with,
um,
Ricky,
so,
so JD,
Washington,
so that was cool.
Um,
and I had met,
I didn't,
I watched these shows.
I didn't know his name was Jay d wash.
I just knew his name is JD from being on set.
I always call him Ricky.
That was it.
Right.
Um,
somebody told me he was related to Denzel Washington and then I find out that
his last name is Washington where I'm on set and I'm looking at the,
the call sheet and I'm like,
Hey,
you're related to Denzel.
And he's like,
yeah,
he has this look on his face.
Like,
Oh fuck,
you know,
you know that.
And I'm like,
I knew he was related,
but I thought he would tell me how at the time.
And I didn't know,
but I later I found out that it was his dad.
Oh Shit,
this is that,
you know,
some from what the information and I've got.
Oh.
And um,
so,
but,
but I'd,
I'd met his dad also worked with him on,
um,
equalizer.
We were for the equalizer to,
we were,
we were helping,
helping him build the scenes.
We choreographing the scenes and teaching the choreography for that.
And I have this,
this,
um,
this thing where he,
he's given me voice lessons.
I have this thing with Denzel Washington giving me voice lessons.
I'll show it to us.
Like he's,
you know,
these,
these tongue twisters that he says to practice annunciating Oh,
you know,
um,
it's kind of dope.
So,
so we're,
we're in,
in the gym,
we're working out and he's like,
so he tells,
he says them to me and he's,
he's like,
you should write this down because my buddy tells him,
yeah,
he does the stuff on Fox,
on the Fox desk for UFC and I'm so he's like,
he pays a little more attention to me at that point.
He's like,
yeah,
he's going back to theater.
He wants to do some theater cause he wants to clean up his stuff.
And so I was like,
you should write this down.
And I'm like,
fuck.
I grabbed my phone and I started recording and then he sees that I'm recording.
So he comes over and he's like,
he's speaking into my phone and I'm like,
I have this shit on my foot.
Had this Denzel Washington Voice coaching me.
Such huge,
super dope.
Right.
So that's what you're here for.
That's what you're going to do other than Fox desk,
you're doing some acting.
Yeah.
It's like I'm a,
I'm a kid again.
Right.
And I have my side,
I had my sag card,
so I have a,
I have a ticket to the theme park.
So why not just try the rights if it's something new to do.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what I'm doing.
I know Bisping springs doing a lot of work.
It means doing a lot.
And I did a movie Bisbing well,
he had a big role in the film come.
We did a lot of shit.
He's doing a lot,
man.
Um,
there's quite a few guys like Jay here on Jay's doing a lot of stunts.
You know,
eye
stents are great,
especially when you're doing fights.
But I'm 155 pounder.
We're out.
I mean like I'm not going to be doing a whole lot of fighting and movies a guy
like,
like Tate right.
Tapes and tapes and doing
exactly.
He got,
he has,
he has the look and he's a big guy so he's getting a lot of work in that
capacity.
Um,
but as a stunt man,
I'm a smaller guy and,
and most of the time when that you want someone my size,
you're going to want someone that can do other things like,
um,
a lot of the gymnast and that type of thing.
And I can do some of that,
but nowhere near as good as those guys.
Right.
Um,
and I'm not learning how to get hit by a car.
Ah,
get lit on fire.
You know what I mean?
Fall on a motorcycle.
That's not happening.
I'm not doing that.
So I want to,
I want to thank,
I want to get better at this acting thing and try that out some cause cause it's
fun.
Also,
I played myself on the,
on the episode of ballers and I was like,
this feels good.
Like the,
the,
the acting thing.
It's like,
I'm,
this is fun.
This is a,
it's,
it's a different kind of rush,
you know,
so new thing.
I'm,
I'm to pick your brain when like I'm going to,
I'm going to ask you for some,
some advice and tips.
You stand up.
I did a couple of,
I did a couple of seasons.
The darn bar.
I did wait to die.
I'm going to do it again.
I mean,
I've done it a few times.
I like it.
If you could do it.
I don't feel like I'm funny.
That's the problem.
You're funny.
Do you can do it.
It's it.
It's worked for everybody.
Yeah.
It seems a lot easier than it is.
It's not easy at all.
No.
Seems like it.
It's not easy at all.
Just talking.
How could that be hard?
But see,
that's the thing.
It's like people like,
man,
you,
you fought in an octagon.
You fucking moon means people.
Isn't that?
It's like,
yeah,
but I'm not looking at them.
You know,
the thing is to,
all new things are difficult.
It doesn't matter what difficult things you do.
Try taking up chest for the first time.
It's difficult to try anything.
Everything that's hard to do is difficult.
It doesn't matter how many difficult things you've done.
You might have a better understanding of how to perform under under pressure
than other people do.
But it's still going to be hard.
It,
yeah,
nothing,
nothing worth doing is easy because it was easy.
Everybody would do it.
I know.
That's the thing.
I um,
the other thing that I'm doing is I have a do a show with this platform called
Pluto.
So I had the show called the thugs you to master in squid show buddy the squid
way.
We got we interview,
we interview guys that got flights coming up.
We do a lot of stuff with fighters,
will get coaches,
we get people that have nothing to do with fighting.
But um,
we make,
we make it fun because we got,
what is this song on Pluto?
What does Pluto,
Pluto,
Pluto is a platform you can get on your iPhone,
on a galaxy snap.
It's an APP.
You can get it on.
I like the playstation on Apple TV and all these things.
Right.
And,
um,
do you know what it is?
You heard of it?
You know,
they got a 24 hour glory channel.
Once they got the glory went in 24,
seven,
they got a fight channel where they have all the glory channel,
glory channel.
Holy Shit.
Okay.
And um,
yeah,
so,
so that's,
we do it over there.
We got a thing,
we do a thing called fight body life where we um,
we watched the fights but we just hang out with it's key.
It's watch the fights when you just hang out and basically do a podcast while
we're,
while we're doing it.
No TV,
it's free.
Everything's free.
No Shit.
Hundred plus channels.
Foreign what you want.
They haven't got everything on then this before.
No.
You know what I'm thinking of?
There's something,
I'm the Amazon.
What is the thing that's on TV?
The Amazon fire.
You can put this on that is that,
that's what I think I've seen it.
I seen,
I seen a dude who had it and it was a whole channel that was dedicated to the
Montreal comedy festival.
They have this Devis standup chat.
Ah,
okay.
Nice.
So what does this show called again?
Um,
the thug Jitsu master and squid shell.
All right.
Uh,
dude,
it's already three o'clock.
Wow.
We've been doing this for how long now?
Over three hours.
Crazy.
Right at a time warp.
How the fuck did that happen?
That's how it goes.
It's weird.
Yeah,
man.
Thank you for,
do we need to say anything more about the Brendan Schaub thing?
Did we cover it enough man,
as far as it goes,
it's just like,
that's where we,
we like,
we need to talk him and hit you,
you know?
Yeah.
So it's a weird situation for me because I love the guy and he's one of my best
friends and also I can't defend what he said cause it doesn't totally make
sense.
Yeah.
And so like what I'm saying,
when I said he talks too much,
I do too.
I say stupid shit.
I don't mean to say stupid shit.
I don't say that stupid.
Um,
I didn't say that thing.
I wouldn't say it like that.
Yeah.
But sometimes you say things,
you don't even know why the fuck you're saying it.
You know?
And a lot of it also was loss,
like just ranting.
Like you,
you're going to these rants and you say shit and then you like see if you can
back it up once you said it.
Yeah.
Like just don't revisit dumb shit.
That's like,
it was insensitive.
It didn't make sense and it was an insensitive and I bet he regrets it.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know.
That's an assumption we're making,
right?
Yeah.
I'm glad I know the guy.
That's why I'm saying it.
Yeah.
He's not a bad guy and you stretch the imagination.
He's awesome.
Um,
I'm not a of the of the,
I'm not the guy saying like,
you're racist saying this,
like that's like my,
my thing is when you're talking about the,
the first,
the initial part of it,
and I conveyed this to him,
you know,
was you're saying me or my brother or my sister aren't good enough to be here.
So like that's,
that's disrespectful because I fully believe that we all are and that,
that,
so that part and he apologized for that and we're cool there,
you know?
And then then,
then why you,
why are you talking about like,
this is what I see in myself because no dog,
that's not,
that's not how it is.
You're not,
you're not a psychologist,
not a psychiatrist.
You have no qualifications to to speak on my mental state.
Like,
like let's just weird too that you guys haven't,
uh,
I think he's on know that's things out.
Sometimes someone says something instead of just straight up saying they fucked
up.
They say I fucked up.
But yeah,
you know,
I fucked it up.
But you know,
he's,
his issue is because of this or you know,
something else is going on with him.
It's making him react this way.
Yeah.
I,
I'm more concerned with his pants,
those shred it up pants and wears those disturbing way more than what he said.
I can't,
can't defend either one.
Yeah,
I'm just wear women's pants.
I don't think they're women's.
They just holding them and hold it on cause it back.
We went through that at the beginning of the show and they have holding them.
It depends on how many holes,
right?
Like depends on like the whole,
well,
if you earn those holes,
like if you work construction,
you got it.
Like a real hole.
Yeah.
You get you,
you get your pen snagged on it.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
You know,
if you're a farmer,
you got like real Barb wire holes and your pants.
That's a different animal,
you know?
That's,
that's okay.
You earn those holes.
You wore your jeans out.
They started ripping in places.
Okay,
okay.
You can't afford to buy some new ones,
but if you paid a lot of mine for pants that are already fucked up,
you saw that shit in a magazine somewhere.
That's what bothers me about Brendan
fucking pants.
I thought that this bothers me too,
but I w what really bothers me,
I like you a lot.
You're always been cool.
And uh,
I think you do a great job.
And I said that very early on when you first started doing it.
I remember I tweeted it or something.
I actually,
and you said it to me too,
the last time I was here,
I was in Joe and I came to do a glory,
a companion with you.
And I remember,
I remember that.
I remember everything you say Joe.
Like even even when did,
cause I don't,
especially when it's about me because there was a time when you were like,
I look at Josh,
he's so strong how he just gets right back up.
It's just,
and he's just,
he's the strongest guy.
Oh,
I remember that.
I love it because there's a couple of times when,
um,
you're not like disparaging of either fighter,
but um,
there's a couple of times when you,
you start seeing the strength in another guy and,
and there's two fights for me where that happened and I was able to just clip
him right as you're giving the other guy some praise.
Perfect.
So I was like,
yeah,
Joe,
shut up guys.
Some love.
Give him some love.
Ladies and gentlemen,
a thug,
Jujitsu master on Twitter is,
what's your Instagram?
Same thing.
Just massive.
All right.
And um,
thug Jitsu master in the squid.
And Squid's shell on Pluto,
Pluto,
Eve Edwards,
ladies and gentlemen.